une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
bienvenue aux sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut nous inviter
d'artistes super chanteuse avec moins
d'une plante on est en ce moment dans
l'espace l'atelier on le respecte on le
répète à chaque fois parce que le studio
sf dans lequel on avait juste idiot dans
le fond qu'avait laquelle ont lancé ce
fait qu on fait de la chaîne les blogs à
tout moment parce que why not c'est à
nous autres on fait ce qu'on veut ok
parce qu'on veut si on a trois espaces
de studio et l'atelier on a le boudoir
on à l'original qui sont disponibles
pour l'occasion ça vient avec un
équipement ça vient avec le technicien
nicole qui derrière la caméra qui vous
savez qu'ils appuient à amener votre
projet qui est une idée
[Musique]
hier
cette semaine un grand plaisir de
recevoir pour la deuxième fois
marc feat on avait reçu en fait l'angle
d'un non lieu de trois ans était un
homme ou premier invité dans la cuisine
dans les tous débuts j'avais vraiment
été un podcast les intérêts de la
cuisine sont quand même marqué les
hôtels à cuisiner et communs ceux qui
ont connu la cuisine c'est si les we
djilali les gens voient donc leurs
marques que vous connaissez peut-être en
tant que personnalité doux et
d'influenceurs qui pendant la petite
naissent en fait mais ce qu'on sait
moins de marque c'est qu'il sait le
fondateur de la compagnie eurolines qui
font du des vêtements de sport qui font
du matériel de sport faudra en fait
voilà faire vraiment pas intéressant
donc on a parlé de
au début de mathias plus de la gestion
comment lui travaillait sur cette
compagnie le petit peu plus le
fonctionnement interne de ces compagnies
là pour les conversations comme évoluer
vers
plus
dégel la motivation vient juste en fait
on apprend un peu plus sur ses toiles de
leicester de marque qu'est-ce qui fait
qui est aussi performant qui réussit à
atteindre l objectif autant au niveau
personnel qu'au niveau des stades et
nice sa routine du jour terme ans pas
intéressant ce genre de podcasts ce que
nous faisons est sous l'eau trouble
mixte a fait encore et encore maintenant
on sort d'un podcast comme ce train qui
motivés prêts à atteindre nos objectifs
puis à vous de penser que c'est vraiment
super cool merci ma marque il ya déjà
comme ça ça paraît qu'ils ont une
capacité cognitive vraiment hors de la
norme piquionne j'ai l'impression qu'ils
répondaient bien voulu nous faire
n'importe quoi il répond pas assez
impressionnant avec on espère vous allez
mais comment s'assurer au tac on a aimé
la voir puis avant ça on va les
remercier nos commandes d'un bon écoutez
le podcast est présenté par auch lac au
chl akena partenaire officiel de
produits alcoolisées et non alcoolisées
ici au studio quand je dis ça ça veut
dire que quand vous venez ici aussi lire
n'importe quel boulot issus du releveur
lieu des produits h l'accès les produits
qu'on boit honnêtement depuis qu'on
collabore avec le clac juin vendus en
flag j'avais arrêté boire d'hommes ouais
ben laden était mort mais là ma vie
aurait une meilleure tournure que
valverde des raisons qui sont évidentes
pour certains qu'ils écoutent mais là
j'ai recommencé à boire tranquillement
parce que je veux c'est l'un des seuls
fonds la duo bien pis je voulais pas que
a recommencé à boire trash
ce que moi des x games dans la you know
me by claude léger
la gamme nano de hochelaga c'est une
gamme de bières qu'ils ne compromettent
pas le goût mais qui permettent de de
vraiment bien boire sans devenir chaud
raid par céder bière qui ont pas
beaucoup de pourcentage à colle donc si
on a un anneau épié par exemple à 2
points 5 % d'alcool nano blanche mais
nous voulons c'est des bières qu'ils
sont super savoureuse fille qui te
touche bafin de même 84 kg foot pouvait
boire dès que je me posais achats liés à
des produits sans accord d'ici qui sont
vraiment bons vraiment comme on dit pour
boire de new moon qui dit ça mais plus
en plus de gens qui font ce choix
douteux qui est cette fois d'avoir
l'option puis quand je buvais pas pu ça
m'arrive encore souvent prendre la gare
aux alcools mais j'en ai testé beaucoup
que la blonde de slides sans alcool est
un croyant qui sinon moi vous savez ce
qu'ils aient cru
j'étais un van du certu mollet but
d'aaron
ramsey une bonne chance aux pieds des
nouvelles saveurs sortie cet été ici
j'ai la range sanguine devant moi que
j'adore à la maison j'en ai pas ici
devant moi mais j ai aussi les socios
limonade selon marc bonnefoy
rafraîchissante sait on a l'impression
de boire quelque chose de léger ça goûte
en plus crimée dans ma peau tant sucré
que en fait c'est presque un gars de ce
parc est nourrie en fait mais c'est
vraiment même si c'est psychoter flûte
et alors c'est vraiment super cool moi
j'adore ça
c'est bien là qu'est l'os est ce
important on y apprend sans merci h like
pour le sport a continué merci à vous
deux d'encourager h leimbach courage sa
croissance certes d'encouragement je
vous encourage à beaucoup d'achats
you know what i mean
c'est le cas cette semaine et présenté
par minsk et nos prix risque des one
nous ça fait vraiment longtemps que tu
as aimé avec minsk et pillé une raison
pour se c'est parce que on utilise leurs
produits au quotidien
quand tu joues quotidien littéralement
quotidien mauler shampoing deux ans dans
leur body wash sur mamadou ch j'en ai
ici à marianne j'en ai dans mon sac en
ce moment j'en ai chinois québec j'en ai
partout parce que c'est le meilleur
produit les meilleurs produits que j'ai
testé d'autres mais l'unocam nokan donc
aucun cas si vous voulez pour casser la
tête puis avoir tous les produits même
skate quand vous avez besoin pour être
pas des bonbons à tous les niveaux si le
platinium package l'adage tamayo les
produits ph mentionné shampoing body
wash you le fameux l'homme blanc 4.2 4.0
qui le rasoi que les produits phares en
fait des manigances la structure de
coûts certains diraient la figure le
monde war cloud skins est le meilleur
que j'ai utilisée dans ma vie la liste
est longue de will work qui pour les
poêle dorer les poils donné pour trimer
saviez comme il faut que ce soit clean
au delà des eaux d'oran qui avec encore
une fois là l'odeur distinctif signature
d'un indice qui sont vraiment superbes
ont ils vraiment con devant la banque
fait que le placement package avec tout
ce temps un homme un seul arrêt pour
tout ce que vous avez besoin d'un code
promo pour vous qui est le sans fil pour
20% le rabais plus le shopping gratuit
honnêtement plomb le dis à chaque fois
que vous êtes vous casser un peu outre
peut-être dans mes joueurs go go pass et
simple plane un package
de bonheur qui t'a vraiment apporté par
citation de payer même pas le shipping
même sans rabais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juillet qui fait je suis un vrai nous
faisons pas de casque journées de
l'entrepreneur puis je te voyais farce
forts partagés massip les foules à
partager comme les
soldats
des foi c'est un enfant de trouver l'eau
chaude et
puis qu'est-ce que ça t'amène aussi de
faire un podcast ben j'aime vraiment ça
partager le jeu
voilà ce que c'est comme seulement ni
peuvent se voit des perspectives ou
c'est normal c'est malsain et mac je
fais peu importe mais des fois ci
c'est justement cet afflux massif de
l'iphone l'ipad c'est ce que je peux
donner du temps par rapport à ceux où je
me concentre sur qu'est-ce que je crie
observé chez plusieurs ouais ouais parce
que 4 suède et quand tu fais des kiwis
néo metal sur ton compte instagram ses
portes en fer mais qu'attend fischer ce
qui se passe que ce genre épique bien de
kuyt 1 2 de ton chemin et puis parce que
c'est ça parce que c'est pas tout le
monde qui sait maintenant tout ce que ça
prend ou les sacrifices que ça prend le
dessus ces mêmes mais moi je te connais
mais je te hais tir je connais pas de
tank sûr je sais pas quel âge je me
projette de réaliser l'emploi comme les
sacrifices qui s'apprend mais
mais ça n'en prend un christ et puis des
offices et le fond de l'entente ton des
fois ça y est je le rappelle avait fait
1 il ya une question c'était comme
qu'est ce tu fais pour pour start et au
début avec les cash-flows tu sur une
question qui comme
qui est vraiment intéressant pour
quelqu'un en béton comme moi avec ma
compagnie picotte cki d'antan dit de
quelqu'un qui le fait puisque tu disais
c'était vraiment pas ce que la plupart
des gens disent le tuer je trouvais ça
intéressant quand même
je l'aimé le suive ring comme à camerone
manège d'un cash flow ou comment ce qui
se fanent de début juin c'est pas ce
qu'est ce que tu répondais juste pour
l'heure on en tourne pour les gens qui
nous écoutent ce que tu répondais
c'était comme prend le moins possible de
l'argent de quelqu'un d'autre parce que
ça enlève le plus possible d'aider des
distractions qui sont externes à toi
maintenant alors que ce que tu entends
souvent surtout pour des compagnies qui
vendent des produits ces genres
faut que tu roules au des buts il faut
que du cash flow fait prendre le capital
que tu peux des investissements qui
réalise aller chercher tu n'étais pas ce
que tu disais je trouve ça intéressant
quand même un mois ce sera tout un tas
de créatures non seulement
plus le dire mais c'est aussi une
personnellement je t'ai tout un
com - soutien arabe uma thurman avait ça
que je sais que je penserais assure jean
tout le temps joue contre damas faut
qu'on discute
mais aussi plus ambitieux désolé
d'avancé
mais moins cccc de quoi qui est dans un
trou vient learning procès ce qui est un
peu de
vocations déclare ce pied
c'est sûr ça prend un peu de temps ouais
mais overtime je sais pas si on a
tendance à comparer mais ces chefs d
entreprise soit avec les plans fêtes de
hoenheim sont plus capables de garder
leur capital puis on le voit tellement
de berne c'est monster puis
souvent aussi il ya un côté image pour
avoir cela j'ai vu tant de funding mais
là j'étais la foire est à la ramasse et
15 millions en investissement et puis la
compagnie a voté en mai et il ya
beaucoup d'enfants qui cartonne un peu
tu apprends
manager plus tellement possibilité de la
fois hyper v jour des problèmes
ça va pas rejoint plus de personnes pour
tomber ça on a besoin de plus parce que
notre projet ça prend plus de temps
voilà c'est faux que tu m'as ne soit
même plus d'apprécier le jeu surtout à
jour chaque site a plus de pression sur
toi mais je photo satellite
réfléchissent plus peut-être plus
derrière notre petit apprend plus sur
toute la face d'activer des capitales
investir avec des spécialistes
de marketing qui est dit me foutais la
fin
ce plat et shane on va pas les
directeurs source on va pas nier une
compagnie qui fait maintenant par la
logistique au complet le tu la prends
peu fait que la poisse et arrive dans un
meeting la logistique peut dire
n'importe quoi ok mi-séance et puis il y
en a que ça peut paraître plus peuvent
être comptés avec ce moi j'aime vraiment
les 90 de titres viennent des choses que
j'ai comme découvre terme c'est que
quatre quand il donne beaucoup de ton
temps quelque chose ben oui tu apprends
plein de stars mais des plaintes
tropiques l'impossible quand engage
quelqu'un tu sais exactement c'est quoi
ça dure exemple le ton était mécanicien
puis un autre en compte notre mécanicien
battait déjà de quoi une carmen puis il
faut utiliser des termes
américaine un procès a été signé mais
c'est minime mais ça crée un genre de
connexion depuis un genre de respecte
pour la personne sans que ce soit
[Musique]
mais ça ma femme attend qu'un j'ai
appris métro acadie mais j'ai tout de
suite - pêche un peu d'argent pour
engager un vote de vol n'ont fait que
les fêtes mais là maintenant on a
développé un métier qui me parlait
quelque chose on peut parler le même
langage ici que je connais sur leurs
clients les grands penseurs il peut pas
de bullshit et médecine c'est négatif
mais qui entrent regardent positif mais
tu peux te voir plus une connaissance la
personne puis
tu peux même choqué lors d'un meeting de
engineering pour le meeting de marketing
mais c'est pas l'exploit et dans toutes
les formes de langage d'une part à la
garde de tout le monde puis tout le
monde parle est avec cette personne ne
sait vraiment intéressant c'est comme
comme bien j'imagine que ça fait aussi
tu
d'un plus grand respect pour le travail
que la personne fait effectuer plus
capable de comprendre mais ton c'est
quoi un vrai deadline c'est quoi tisser
quoi respecter vraiment le travail à
faire pilar l'ampleur des choses
l'abaissement de terre mais aussi même
savoir justement mieux planifier ouais
mais tu peux aussi c'est la personne du
groupe bloc béton mais tout le dg
véhicules maladie paysanne le clip le ce
facile parce que amandes tous égaux si
tu as déjà dans le fond ces casemates et
un professeur d'un jour c'est juste le
camp qui était de faire monter ou qui
ont de la mise à pied c'est pas de juste
donner la réponse est de justement qui
est la personne se développe aussi dans
le processus s'est fixé deux
puis les développer si tu trouves pas
solution par à même d'apprécier vont
juste à la playmate le suffixe où
ce
sera une bonne vision du truc qui
d'aller plus loin d'une zone de temps
avec le studio non non on n'a jamais
pris je m'en sers n'da personne ne
puisse allah fait justement que des fois
fallait jusqu'à sa tête pour eux pour
trouver une façon de gamme juste arrivée
qui justement on a appris en faisant
qui juste d'engager plus de monde on le
fait aussi puis on s'est rendu compte
que c'était pas nécessaire de toi je
sais que là non pas constat parle et une
disait que c'est parce que quand je suis
venu au bureau drive
personnes
en énergie genre pour la grosseur du
truc vous êtes personnes
par mois de tous un peu parce que
j'imagine vous avez jeu m'avait déjà dit
le cam pour des combats ni équivalente
le vous avez comme le tiers des employés
d'une compagnie qui avec ce chiffre
d'affaires le pire c'est quoi la ligue
derrière ce
nom 9,9 en est à plus de monde ouais
puis
c'est quand même un dentiste à des
compromis c'est une grosse campagne de
marine à ses efforts mais qui comporte
dans le fond de la
longue procession s'est rendu compte
qu'il est on engageait de samatan du
monde à employer en vidéo marketing tout
puis on n'avait pas tout le temps au
début j'étais plus petit la personne qui
apporte plus qu'un japonais une femme
puis des fois tu as passé maître
d'oeuvre a donné pour des inquiétudes ce
faire
je fais pas mal mais maintenant tu peux
juste tu fais juste du vidéo va donc
temps pour que la personne s'engage à
faire du vidéo mais aussi de gérer les
réseaux sociaux mais ton pour publier
les trucs pour vous même des enfants
plus de 10 depuis ses pages aux joies
des shooting vidéo aujourd'hui pub
commercial c'est nous on n'est pas au
stade où on a juste besoin d'être un
fait on
avec la cage de toutes ces mêmes should
i voyages et prépa puis on a beaucoup de
caractère extrême fait que que ce soit
classement ça provient de mon travail de
n'importe où un public c'est le chat les
arrange parce qu'il était un peu je
sortais le laptop yvon le seul pavillon
la peine ça a besoin d'avoir tout le
team de ce poteau bureau mais on a
quelqu'un au bureau qui ce que tim de se
porter puis ça m'a fait pour elle le web
des tirs au but rouge attaque auvergnate
ans on regarde tout avec
m constat les athlètes super deformed
encore en comptant les athlètes même
peut-être jeu face à l'école je pourrai
marcher que seulement quand internet
jean 20 21 22 puis l'utilisé 9 au bureau
- fait qu'il ya plus d'athlètes
finalement c'est plus d'athlètes sur
pérol qui était d'emplois mais c'est pas
jeudi être la série contre ces pratiques
ce puits par rapport aussi qu'on est
dans notre salle le matin prochain
bureau contre elle a construit ballon
est repoussé 40 c'est aussi dès la fin
des spas rapidement et tout ce qui s'en
vient dans son line up de comme projet
qui ont si gentiment on a notre média
depuis on va l'aider oui depuis les
après ça qui va embraser seul ce stade
là bas on aille acheter personnes bien
les sous traitants c'est quand même
c'est quand même payant parce qu'il ya
quand il ya vraiment beaucoup de gens de
qualité sont à l'externe section d'aidé
qui sont des rayons des packs sont pas
nécessairement le même au québec la ccr
actions partout ouais le monde cherche
c'est
des fruits des noix futur lanceur
alors qu'on croise à des travailleurs
autonomes c'est qu'ils sont vraiment ça
à coeur canal puis qui charge le prix
qui bataillent vodafone qui est des
projets de m quand je perds ou pour ceux
qui m'attendent éditeur de photos notés
en a neuf vins fins et qu'on peut le
tapis mais la grêle vous les connaissez
vous un puissant bon oeil on pensait le
screening tout c'est parce que avant
mathon avait quelqu'un qui ait quitté
les photos hot que c'était pas du
marketing mais c'était comme les shoots
mais là
on a des lancements maintenant on va
s'enticher par cars entiers de produits
resté stable à ce décor de sa maîtresse
même d'être shootée desdites études d'un
cancer à l'intestin mais le matin black
friday bien sûr cette club tu as besoin
de quoi là tu n'étais qu'un l'appui long
il va marquer on shoote au bureau ont
fait toute l'aquitaine cas précis mais
on n'en voit plus y aller mais job
dating cape à cenon le plomb fini
farchana monde le feedback la personne
sur mille en pleine extase puis pourquoi
on est autant effet chine c'est des
opérations
c'est ce que toi tu as fait dans le
dernier 2 1 paru complètement
ouais quand même assez violent mais
c'est que justement on commence à être
plus il ya des stages de compagnie en
fait nous faxer
58 chez je peux maintenant manège à un
million c'est quand même facile de tuer
pour jeudi beaucoup avaient braqué deux
trois quatre
étudiants qui vont chaque stage
des nouveaux systèmes de nouveau pressé
surtout de mettre en place puisque
rencontre exemple les retours échange
c'est bien plus compliqué il y en a plus
de volumes plus tellement que c'est
quand même deux semaines ou whatever
works par mois c'est assez facile et
également du fait que la fois que ça
donne mais qu'attend 9 45 ans qui rend
passionnant nous même pas attendu black
friday des échanges et céder certaines
personnes mais tire le foot mais djoko
en place qui fait sens puisque les
clients c'est rapide c'est la marche du
monde celle qui fut aussi quand je pense
bien activisme et on laisse failli virer
ça peut faire dix ans soit sylvain
mathon zürich ots certains revenus par
rapport à ton marqué tout ton type de
business que c'est rendu que le tmb est
quasiment tout les secteurs pour aller
on accepte puis se massait les flamands
se plante pas ce que leurs systèmes sont
pas assez réfléchi puis le jeu trop de
pertes partout mais un constat d merci
c'est ça m'a pris un méchant bout de
deux ans de cela parce que c'était un
métier de tout mais ça commence à être
beaucoup de domaines le tir a fallu
qu'on soit vraiment plus le pouvoir
toute ma nature juste parce que c'est
juste que tu fais payer
les erreurs qui va aussi comme dumas
nous intrigue et il y en a pas mal de
clients un système qui solide très
content de te bile de scotch pour mon
genre
ça a été ça en fait la raison pourquoi
tu es tout peu disparu du paysage tout
ça c'est que la manne est la belle nice
prennent trop de place traiter les
points chauds comme juste moi je savais
que j'avais c'était inévitable que tout
à fait mature des retouches en chine
stable qu'on va tout enfant ouais ouais
ok ce matos au stade exemple où le
design et des produits quand en design
et on sort puisqu'elle toussaint près du
paradis cette techno dizaine ont sorti
trop tôt
[Musique]
c'est fois qu'il met genre c'est aussi
toutes nos systèmes aujourd'hui de
lasers des autres machines puis comment
est-ce qu'on peut empower le team joest
hamas je sais plus créatifs dans un sens
parce que s'ils ont besoin de voir juste
le début des jeux 2 jusqu'à 6 répétitifs
puisqu'on va tout le temps forts puis le
pcc la fabrique l'expérience client à
l'impôt robotique ne s'est souvent le
monde thématise mais les clients après
saluée par un bon feeling comme je sens
un hamburger
finalement la forme le personnel et en
plus ça que c'est si menacée c'est même
mieux que c'était que si on le faisait
ressembler à quoi ta vie mais tu en
penses
faites en même temps c'est moi je vois
dominique là dedans puis pour moi
c'était dans ce domaine avec 90 par nuit
je
mets ma mousse mousse à
8,50 à faisait pitié on se parlait des
fois puis
ça veulent absolument une scène comme si
ces gens si le réveil à 4h le matin avec
ton expression nespresso puis le mend
cecos faisait total et devant son ordi
du cas des charts faisait du prime sur
20 johnston non-stop
journée j'ai
pu
s'écarter faty aux pointes à face à
green way
puis
parce que t'es pas le choix je mais je
ne te laisser de côté le traîner
spécialement des cas c'est pas bon de
s'entraîner ne soit plus stable aussi
comme 3 c ce qui jetait aussi m côté
médical personnel
puis ça faisait un bout de temps
depuis 2010 le même temps je commence à
2009 a montré les plus intenses pis je
vais m'arrêter puis des jets peuvent
l'être times puis je suis à 3 400 vidéos
par aneel plus partir des compagnies
programme années j'étais plus dans un si
la routine qui chante époque je
contribuais de plus de vert à liu dans
mon cas je devenais bonne soirée tout le
monde devrait boire de ton propre quand
une petite partie est ce que tu as
l'impression que le monde aussi non ben
pour nécessairement dans le monde a
demandé mais c'est plus cher d'après
moussa transperce et j'ai jamais écrit
un vidéo jamais secrétairie encore
obscures mais genre
jamais je n'y en a pas un juif que j'ai
puis c'était juste un mandataire passe à
gagner juste route jeudi je connais mon
tapis je connais les a formés ça respire
je critique un peu rêveur winlock six
matches gamme est un moyen le pied c'est
une bonne ressource n'est pas juste la
vidéo il y aurait peut être minutes et
disputerait matin et je peux je parle
d'un tapis puis c'est juste dans mon
char shooter au lieu dit mais tu me
files mais je partais
certains cas pas de créer un despote
mais moi je trouvais que je voulais plus
à prendre cette même dans ce processus
j'apprenais vraiment notable j'ai quand
même pas mal
je me sens prêt je me sens plus c'est
que je
me sens personnellement si tu peux
mais la période qui était justement de
vraiment focus sur le business ppi étant
justement dernier deux ans est déçue
parce que tu avec talent est pas un
choix
faire autant ou ou parce que je tue vous
luttez mais surtout les femmes qui tous
les passants qui se faisait
passer pour toi de da par mois sur les
épaules des légumes dans situation
relative ce c'est une question souvent
qu'il rate un voyage fait à la famille
cac 40 bull la base c'est les femmes
deux cibles parce que justement j'avais
louvre view d'être qu'est-ce qui se
passe ce n'est pas juste maintenant
départementaux mais maintenant tout est
connecté tout ça parle
des bulls maintenant je m engage une
équipe sont pris plus de temps en feed
back des maisons des puits d'eau revenez
puisqu'elle le monde comprenne que je le
fasse puis deux âmes attend de tous tout
changer ceux de rased ce qu'on va voir
quel point sur ce
thème est
pisté complet marque reconstruire la
structure le tas business au complet
femme puis on a tout juste deux heures
maintenant avant cette
bataille à l'épinglé mutation avec le
rapid storage lance ramon sabella
fallait d'élite des fare alais manager
cela on avait un serveur
ses bésicles le montage acquis par
google drive on a vraiment tout un
meilleur goal drive tottenham qui est
important dans le système qui peut
ouvrir des farl de chercher tout
vraiment rapidement fait legault se
rendent à la naissance de caisse que
quelqu'un fait qu'il repose répétés puis
que les autres peuvent utiliser aussi
faire un exemple
la designer pense à mon survêtement puis
à dire que le futur si c'est l'objectif
initial puis ça va être un produit de
google ça va être un t-shirt puis ça
c'est le fabrique puisque c'est dans cet
ordre c'est les couleurs sont qui vont
indisponibles ou potentiellement
disponibles mais al ahram déjà ses
derniers livres mais la majorité des
compagnies responsables a écrit produit
à la pause ils y sont en position y
arrive plutôt qu'il y en a qui sont pas
toutes nos modèles playon une liste un
peu les peuvent oublier des pistes où il
faut qu'ils rentrent les mêmes données
dans le fond qu'il hostage ouaga la
largeur en régie en fac ci se fait tout
de a à z est le même mais le tout le
cite un exemple banal mais
ça c'est que tout le monde sauf du tapis
on peut juste plus créer puis à penser
qu'ils sont peu plus au lieu de juste
fait date entre deux mondes que tout va
sur leur lit commerciales avec ses cris
copie dans les url raccourcies y ont
copié un produit maison chapais failli
parce que c'est une couleur jean py la
haye objets ayant oublié rentrée telle
taxe pour qu'il y ait dans telle
collection la sortie de starfox overtime
et 47 produit maintenant sur chaque fois
et ce après une semaine des as le tpr
halak description de la photocopie sur
chacun playtech malquier déterminer leur
propre description sur un autre nous on
fait plus épineux il s'inscrit tout seul
mais je peux comprendre vraiment
l'efficacité de tout ça parce que juste
moins maintenant sur une pique à juste
créé un nouveau produit c'est compliqué
je peux pas croire c'est en fait 300 400
par année le cd produit le cheap show
quand même parce lorsqu'il faut que tu
rends vraiment toutes les déceptions
baird soudure entre là dans le hot seat
là ça commence à être vraiment long
juste pour créer la page 20
j'en fais en chèques je trouve
ça pas besoin d'un système qui complexe
avec plein de conditions plus grand
quand on est dedans mais un produit mais
comme souvent c'est le thé comme c'est
un problème je sortais des produits dans
une collection cinq ans c'est long on a
presque insultant ouais ouais
c'est à qui j'avais demandé dans le fond
si tu attends tu disais tu es avant
qu'ils se faisaient plus
tp sa carrière l'inflation fait n'est-ce
pas ce qui te fait de la vidéo puis 10
start et des business
c'est quoi les business dans ce sens
qu'il est maintenant et lloris mais tu
as tu d'autres business à parallèles à
ceux où maintenant devenu conscience aux
rays menaient
qu'on a vendu y en a je peux parler
[Musique]
et maintenant tu peux tu parler pourquoi
tu peux pas parler
les méthodes parce que tu appartiens de
désastre quelqu'un d'autre puis un nom
d'emprunt sa massue mais c'est des
affaires déroulé dans le fond qui avait
piqué comme étant la personne qui lâche
t on qu'est ce je ne sais pas ce qui
m'a
marqué
c'est plus moi mais se passe et ils
m'ont pas renoncé à qui veut attaquer ce
qui s'en vient on va commencer à mettre
suppose de prendre le montant déjà très
peu de monde il ya ce 6e - les pokemons
fils qui donne l'argent - gens pour
écouter tout un tous les versants sur
l'ice était de quel produit 6e plus
juste toi ça soit autre chose qui donne
un appui si tu m'aimes pesage à duras
espaces désertiques de ben laden je peux
qui est des pieds de carthage à denek le
site du film night race et la dépense
assez cyclique j'avance et plus gros
qu'une personne c'est seul objectif
c'est encore c'est l'objectif que je
vois pas est un porte-parole récemment
c'est moi j'ai beaucoup d'allées j'ai
fait beaucoup d afin d' opération de
mechtras le problème c'est seulement
j'ai parce que dans l'image de rise me
tentait pas plus de place qu'un autre
athlète s'est fixé
mais moi je
fais déjà
braqué en fait je m'en fous de ce
[Musique]
sitting in d'ailleurs c'est pour une
question de logistique mettons que
ça changera pas les choses
[Rires]
vers ce site et mettez en carrière
guillemet france a refusé on sais pas
qu'est ce que les réseaux sociaux
mais même compagnie une fois qu'elles
existent car groupe de chances qu'elle
existe dans le temps mais c'est pas un
matin ce sama pour mettre ma sécurité
personnelle que certains jugent pas
besoin urgent aux dons genre
je te mariage parce que j'aime je disais
je veux tu peux te tendre une main
aucune attache mesures passées au
matériel de mon combat ma maison prenez
votre mal value c'est en tout cas ce que
j'ai appris que je peux leur bep
obligent un médecin apte à créer
ses succès ainsi patrice mme soit cet
extrait d'une maison peut encore mais
c'est pas nécessaire mais ça c'est
simple on peut repartir sur autre chose
le mail
l'idée que y'a rien qui est important
c'est quelque chose que je me je
commence à me rappeler pierre à me dire
souvent puis de juste quelque chose qui
arrive magnachip qui arrive puis au
final tu reality lyon comme sorti les
images de l'univers
plus de voix se fait comme chemin y'a
rien qui est important y'a rien qui est
important c'est donc la vie humaine
c'est juste mini
spect de boussières semaines deviennent
dépressifs
sais pas je ne viens pas dépressif
mettons pige pas moins
juge pas moins j'ai pas moins en vie
dessous de la planète sur vivace que la
race humaine sur vie sur la planète
le tout changement climatique maintenant
lundi tout ça mais ça enlève un genre de
poire ses épaules c'est tout les toutes
les la pression la société de
réussir ces choses là au final c'est toi
envers toi même tu sais c est ce que le
moins je suis contente oui ce que je
suis comme tu dis si demain matin et
tout disparaît j'aime vraiment qu'en
fait ce que tu me dises de malades qui
disparaît ce qui reste c'est toi ce que
tu as appris des connaissances puis ta
capacité de survivre de rebâtir ou de
recommencer et ils puissent y sont donc
de se dire ça ça fait comme ça enlève un
peu de pression les gens ça enlève même
temps comme la pression pas pour moi
c'est parce que le mmm attendre ce que
j'aime qu'on emploie au moins ma famille
à fondamente mais moi personnellement
j'ai pas besoin de grand chose si ce
gène jones et j'aimerais j'aime les
mailles sting tout seul mais c'est pas
de quoi que j'ai mon cerveau était pas
attaché pendant toute la saison je pense
qu'il risque à marmaris parce que
c'est sa place à mathieu lèvres je t'ai
amman et j'étais même plus heureux quand
j'avais trois en percement compte de
banque les étudiants qui
étaient justes
il ya des phases même si d'après le
titre comme ton ego s'attache à presque
jamais eu jamais été
acquis avec la chine mais mois passé
avant maintenant tu sais comme actif il
par rapport à quelque chose cependant et
je filais jusque
là
c'est impossible que je fais c'est ce
qui est bien c'est moche d'étape d'en
face de la ville et les gens de
certaines façons mais aussi si c'étaient
mes propre tape à moi même me sucer le
feeling était à pratiquement pas tant -
réfection
genre mais je vais jusqu'à la fin de la
journée le juge godbout 29 mai
myboox arrêtés - six mois
ces quads hors fortis et pam et on le
sait la fait travailler aussi fort
suppose que ça t'apporte justement béton
financièrement afin c'est quoi
c'est quoi en fait dans vicky coren du
bonhomme c'est l'expérience de données
expérience et que j'avais fait ces gens
ont été créés quelque chose que les
rentes ai repensé à ce que tu fais une
exposition de
l'artiste will enjoy ap ap un tout mais
c'est d'avoir partagé dans le partage et
puis les pilotes et c'est un feeling qui
était petit peut le voir dans la valeur
des autres peu importe le temps mais
j'aime c'est pas un an faudra je
montrais montrer et puis je veux être
approuvée par les autres mais juste de
donner une expérience ou d'alléger des
fois les chrétiens du monde nous et le
savoir aussi que mon nom est un peu même
si mon nom est attaché à gc je crie du
bon travail depuis que le gosse et qu'il
a cédé legacy que celle où peu le temps
toute idée on entre dans l'univers et
tout mais on peut quand même pour créer
une ligne rouge et noir il faut que ça
mousse puis vous faites moi c'est plus
d'un qu'est ce que je préfère contribué
qui est demain ça va être mieux
même si je puis loeb il ya déjà il ya
des couettes et puis factice a commencé
avec des enfants il faut beaucoup de
ressources d'un
mois ce sont des villes qui y siègent
j'ai pour qu'est ce que je ferais jean
becker andré pied le prochain tour mais
ses marques en changer positivement le
monde enfants ouais mais
ça va je
peux pas m'en fous tu food and drug
enjoy vraiment
la musique
doit être jugée trop musique
jamais mais quatre ans parle en fait
juste non c'est pas vrai a dit m qu'ils
perdent dans ma vie où est ce que je
fais ce qu'il fait
déjà là mais coop sinon résistance
pratiqués je dormais vous recommencez
puis je faisais je ce jeu sûrement
quelqu'un qui me dit aman et petit plus
la quitter mais comme toi dans le
dernier deux heures je les fais pas
l'intérieur de ma vie je m'étais investi
boschi après ce fait que je
sais c'est parce que moi je trouve si
comme d'exprimer l'envié de nager 1 210
prennent place et sur un genre de cinq
ans que le web qui était faible mais on
peut relativiser puis
par exemple le monde là dessus tout le
monde lui en perspective mais parce
qu'il ya ce soit au travail travail
n'ont roulé foot entre la vie en musique
riche en part je travaille jeune john
genre jeu mais le truc personne qui va
voir un artiste du travail trop parce
que c'est comme a écrit quelque chose
qui fait quelque chose il vit et qui
sont ses émotions son âme c'est sûr mais
ma foi je m'intéresse au line up pour
créer quelque chose d'enfantin cris de
quoi mais
painting qui n'est pas visuel pour le
monde mais c'est pour ça qu'on
il faut que ce beaucoup sur qu'est-ce
qu'on crypte ce soit vraiment la baisse
que ça peut être le moment avec nos
capacités qu'on mette en doute et il m'a
dit les personnes qui aiment se fait
quand même bien je connais votre plateau
travers qui sont nécessaires jeudi c'est
vraiment quand tu commences à avoir mal
aux doigts de pratique mais sauf que
d'enfoncer moment là tu vois ce come
back il loge me fait chier mais pour
éventuellement dans vie sa cape de super
g qui en général est maintenant
chacun codage en attendant plus de
l'image de ce petit jeu le patin de
gérer script qui l'allument c'est le
résultat c'est qu'est-ce que ça amène
après mais regardez derrida cas de paul
von sponeck gentil klaus la taille peut
être mes cd m un groupe ce décès on dit
souvent mais ce genre de cas il est
évident le présent oui ce fut un cousin
mais si tu veux créer de quoi t'as pas
le choix des pièces de quoi aujourd'hui
qui devrait rapporter
ce que j'aime autant à l'entraînement
aussi six sata prince était par nature
c'est vraiment un pilote et comme elles
savent à peu petit mais des mecs d un
peu meilleur pas si tu le world d'avoir
de temps pour donner pour de quoi qui
vont être que thomas route mais ça c'est
vraiment c'est un bon parallèle parce
que quatre d'entre inning complètement
ce genre t'as envie de vomir tous les
gens qui filtrent moi je prends la corse
qui maintenant la natation à l'époque
des fois on faisait des pratiques là je
te garantis que personne n'a piscine qui
est en train de se dire ça c'est une
fois ça y'a pas un show dans piscine
tout le monde absurde d'entre eux n'ose
dire s'il estimait qu'on n'est pas prêt
à me faire du genre tout le monde a
envie de vomir je suis capable d'enlever
mes bras chargés les prestations à 195
part ça fait une heure qu'on est là
dessus depuis le juge aux images plus à
ces cas tu touches me raffin
défièrent un pas vers mac de l'avoir
fait puis le résultat qu'on vit ici
l'objectif final est comme plus
important que le moment dans lequel peu
en train de payer puis c'est dans ce que
des capable de trouver la gratification
par rapport à l'institut cite des
douanes de fonte mais oui mais c'est
vrai que maintenant tu lui dis ça fait
comme sens que le sport
ait amené se mettant dans ma vie comme
dans un défi parce que tu étais juge
quelqu'un et je demande de travail en
piste et qui
pour qu'il est satisfait c'est quelque
chose qui ne cessera bien portants pour
justement construit de quoi puis c'est
vrai le ticket cancon angers seconde a
vraiment qu'on était d'afghans je sais
je sais que ses hôtes
des fois ce genre d'entraînement
surprise ou est ce qu'on faisait des
métiers charles à martigues dit à son
fils en gaza pour croquer si les petits
les step back dit qu'il ya plein moment
de ma vie où est-ce que c'est dur
puisque c'est paul von mais le big
picture de ma vie je laime 10 nice fac
ci comme le les difficultés des
sacrifices pour t'amener un niveau de
manière générale plus loin parenté dans
l'approché comme tout le temps il loge
entre la peine est encore plus à jour ça
du réputé comme traditionnellement mener
mais la perception du temps devient
tellement altéré loyalement mon
beau-frère fait son doctorat en psychose
sur la perception du temps lui stranger
d'ultra marathon le fait que poser des
trente deux 32 km en montant puis ils
calculaient comment le temps peut
paraître vraiment plus long à certains
moments comme un temple passait vraiment
plus vite et lui dans sa tête c'était
que dans les premiers 10 km de son 32e
kilomètre mettons le times passe
vraiment vite mais que le dernier 10 km
colère infiniti puis c'est ça que c'est
le résultat des sept îles mais tellement
sous stress ils m'ont et se dire
maintenant combien de temps ça que cette
claque un clic sur cinq ans a fait du
second puis le monde cliquez sur ce que
ça veut dire que cette seconde mais le
dernier 10 secondes il était genre était
vraiment tordu par la perception j'avais
l'impression que c'était du second mais
c'était genre cinq ans et ça c'était
vraiment moins longue y'avait pas il
fait beau et très peu utilisés comme
cobayes kantigui même quelque chose
comme 6 baies sata et c'était aussi que
des fois maintenant quand tu games est
peut-être vraiment immergé dans dans 1
dans un jeu ou un événement virtuel tais
toi quand tu fais du curling ça doit
être ça doit être la même chose ou est
ce que l'a emmené dans un flou si tu
t'assois puis le titulaire tu penses à
fait une heure ça fait 4 heures
sur une affaire
c'est que c'est pas le temps d'aller où
les cartons bruns mesure
de gaming verser 5 2 heures
d'entraînement quand même deux ans
pendant deux ans les gaming
est peut-être passé la nuit blanche au
complet
afin qu'ils les sexes
tu avais fait ben julien je viens aaron
notre ami commun
il m'avait dit il m'a donné un concert
en certain piquant et il dit document
doute pas ce que lui disent mon plus
grand regret c'est de bord documenté
tout est dit j'ai des photos de moi dans
mon appart etc des boîtes de suppléments
partout autour de moitié à jean reyssier
faire des petits enfants on est rendus
dans un style warehouse à blainville
puis quitte à tout partager une story ou
est ce que c'était je suis pas problème
que c'est le site qu'il fallait mais
c'est l'évolution dont tu étais lien
intellectuel
fait que ces genres dalphond pour ceux
qui écoutent vie d'homme ces gens rien à
faire que des crimes et ont un mot
maintenant le mot c'est super rise
mettant donc le plat presse s'est décrit
un mot qui est l'hymne qui a right place
et gère vêtements la partie des
vêtements spelling et plein d'autres
mots tout les mots sont comme reliés à
ce genre de matrix fait clairment et on
cherche un mot des crimes dont vêtements
ça t'amène à ceux là s'ajoutent aux
mines le dit capable de refaire des
liens pour essayer de garder toutes les
idées en une seule place la vie tout à
partager une story ou est-ce que c'est
l'évolution de turpan dans les derniers
2 ans pis même c'est une scène c'est ça
devient tellement sa voie romaine le
petit ça c'est tout mais mes connexions
intellectuelle pour incapable de me
retrouver facilement mais penser ça est
obligé de fils de mentalement me
retrouver facilement là mes pensées le
même si ces tests est innocent parce
qu'on pense pas le meilleur moment d'y
penser à ta prend de court puis le
pokémon se rappeler d'une annexe thing
mais c'est des connexions que des fois
même si d'étape et c'est ça t'amène voir
cette idée où ça devenait un concept que
c'est une autre forme et c'est tu peut
le relier à un autre industrie ou un
autre domaine où et puis ab-so-lu-ment
questionner ces monarchistes un soutien
qui est écrit pour les eaux se
retireront fac inquiet qui font la
lecture peu importe ils prennent un
autre puits dans le fond chacun des
modes pour lui m je sais pas ce qu'en
france et mettez les parents qui sont
encore
otages à
les
mettre en mots qui après ça tu peux
cliquer sur le monde ça devienne enfants
quand même deux notes mais tape tomlin
qui dans un autre dans un building je te
fais toi youtube vidéos d'écouter un peu
cassant portes et après ce bain
le lob avant qu'ils voyaient l'argent
c'est que tu vois toutes les versions de
toutes les connexions de tout dépenser
mais tu vois les liens chacun le match
est arrivé que cette idée
les
autorités tentent d'apprendre un nouveau
domaine de la recherche sur un domaine
tu m'étonnes qu'ils et elles mots la
france aux côtés d'intel tel concept lui
rentrer dedans qui se sent en lien avec
ça se fait que tu le fais par année afin
c'est fou je trouvais vraiment vite le
dis tu peux retrouver des amphores tu
fais quand même genre ce mot là
maintenant qu'elle sait où j'avais
entendu six ans qui était lié à une
étude est que je suis grecque le clac
c'est la sorte suite non seulement il
s'est ensuite comme un autre solde clé
aurait dû tourner la page puis
questionné sud est est en forte hausse
comme un jardin pour une autre mais
celle de jean noir
questionner si
cela s'était
fait par rapport
il y avait un chercheur dans son allmend
chercheurs de sociologie puis lui
l'enfant il y avait des démocrates et
les cas persiste lui c'est un des
des personnes qui a le plus écrit dans
son acte il sortait des majeurs boucle
gros de ses origines puis dans le fond
il y avait c'est notre rôle peeling
pièces et notre corps de femme moderne
disait quelque chose il se faisait le
saut mairie à 4 s'incline bien précieux
il y avait sept les choux box puis
il mettait sonatel freebox puis il
mettait des liens qui se serre lié avec
telle ou telle chose peut y avait un
numéro mettant le plugin qui comme ce
fac en lui après c'est arrivé près ces
notes plus il fallait qu'ils écrivent de
quoi il faut recenser toutes ces notes
il était le tout sur une table puis il
ya toutes les connexions plus possible à
écrire il faisait un plus gros sous
marine enfants de toutes ces notes qui
fasse sens dans un structure interne
puis le lac la technologie freebox après
une carte on part en fa cup obsidian
conspiracy gratuit en plus nous d'aller
manger d'années maintenant contribuer
a
[Musique]
justement fait apprendre quelque chose
le rentrer là dedans puis ça permet
d'aller
très fair et à sa femme n'ont fait que
tout qu'est ce que j'apprends à matonge
assure une fois j'ai dit certaines notes
que c'est pas des rêveurs wins out le
fonds cd note que c'est juste un article
puis taipei prendre toutes les
initiatives comme ce chiffre énorme
attendant jean yves outils continue to
video 3 plein notes sont quand même dame
puis après c'est de la danse matadi
concept peut boire aux dames puis le jeu
ça devient comme une matière guînes jeu
max et une note que d'enfance plus un
oui car de toutes qu'est ce que tu lui
dis c'est un sommet lui dans le sens de
toute la campagne chat comme surveiller
quand même ligne que washington
attend le contenu initial fax vois
certains effets que je m'attende
solitaire au terme des
pourparlers dans son interview dans un
peu de gaz dans ses livres mais a
toutefois estimé john patterson comme
étant l'auteur de
la bastille peu question assez du tout
c'est que tu peux être comme sur une
table tu peux les étals et enfin toutes
les vols de la mort et le droit de
s'y trouver note b ne soit pas là au
tout après une new window mais c'est le
taulier fait pour ce fait que tous les
états les plus petits peuvent vraiment
bol d'antenne à tous peut les sortir
aussi mais tant pis ça a été super
pratique donc quand j'étais étudiant
vraiment pratique parce que met donc
sorti années je faisais même à mon
mémoire de maîtrise puis je travaillais
sur le journalisme littéraire des années
80 aux états unis piste est super
précités fait que chaque fois que je
sortais des études puis maintenant qu'il
y avait une mention du journalisme gonzo
mettons des adresses thompson qui de mon
sujet principal belge que j'aurais pu
l'inscrire là dessus bien passé quand
c'est venu le cash est venu le temps de
rédiger mes quarante pages dessert
autour de journalisme terrab du gonzo
j'aurais pu lé japon comme un concept
maintenant j'aurais eu des attaques
toutes les notes seraient apparus
directement de mes deux mais bien de ce
concept loti que j'aurais pu facilement
avoir accès à qu'est ce qui s'est dit à
tel moment puis même si ça c'est fou
c'est incroyable comment tu l'avais
montré ça m'avait vraiment j'étais sur
le cul mais je regardais tachetée rouge
ses jambes mais ne s'arrêtent pas de
grossir selon l'évolution humaine
djar djar de boulemane ans ça va de
soi toutes les deux dans le fond tout le
monde peut la déplacer votre feeling
avec je les vois ça obsidian point m 10
ces sites est gratuit au début il ya un
pylône inc passé
nazi - read ta 27 obligé d'écrire
bâti créé un peu encore damon mais c'est
j'aurai
le format y était
mais c'est plus d'un
mètre exemple se fait acheter avec space
peas fait acheter acheter
deux puis
trois italiens
n'ont cessé lyon cette année
jusque
là
les outils city
celui-là métier je t'entends des anneaux
par cas ce qui t'attend citer qu'un
exemple du genre d'outil cheese au
quotidien mais ton pour
acquis tonton peu importe à ce que ça
soit en sommeil ou que ce soit justement
comme ceux pour qui choque de 10 que tu
apprends d'un titre mais dans le genre
d'applications qui utilisent au
quotidien est en jeu j'en avais plus ça
va mais j'en ai limité de gens éduqués
dans l'espace dans le trou jean-claude
simple ce conflit à la gemmi ceux
d'intel c'est du foot français çà fait
perdre du temps puisque anonyme moi
c'est ça le trou 6113 des enfants mais
en général othman en développement
personnel obsidienne c'est pas mal celle
que j'utilise
après
parfois togo pour achever ses courses
avec avec le
web c'est un bracelet qu fait
sensiblement chose que le moring dans ce
mail mai
vraiment bien ton ton niveau de stress
sur ton corps je suis proche de ma
pile à l'interface adresse magali avait
somme accueille rochette yard cursus moi
et toi pas de casque et une cyclo cross
sonata de cyclo-cross international
beaucoup de temps patrick localement les
bandits
pourquoi j'en ai trop c'est juste parce
que je t'aime à un peu documenté les je
vois tout mystère euros plus frais non
mais je garde tout bien précis mais je
crois que réfléter le genre à telle
période et senna est le quatrième et en
europe tout petit tremplin tu vois j'ai
acquis mais dans cette période mon
sommeil était dégueulasse hui étaient
moindres à cause de cette poule faire
des connexions par rapport à temps des
tout débuts de pierre - mas cap
d'interroger le mieux ce qui fait que se
facturent pas de tête ma tante adaptant
d'entraînement acquis aujourd'hui je
vois qu'ils m'ont fait ce qu'il peut
souvent
[Musique]
c'est ma faute à moi si j'ai pas eu à
cette semaine moi aussi je me suis fait
un commitment
des fois je sais je suis vraiment trop
haute et jouer que ça vaut plus
productifs mais souvent c'est comment
c'était ma faute parce que j'ai fait est
là franchement j'ai dit oui et elle a
formé chez censé dénoncer fait que je
m'inflige pareil pn extrême mais je vous
conseille plus à démontrer ning fait de
la traque est arrivé au début j'avais
dit non parce la terre tomber dans un
destruction merci dans le fond on peut
en parler des sorties de ce deux ans la
dernière main gros changement dans ta
vie dans sa vie personnelle s'étaient
séparés puis le terreau tomber dans dans
la destruction physique les animaux à
l'animal est ressorti dans le fond cet
outil ce
nom c'est quoi déjà qu'il est dans mes
plans je le recommence alors commencé à
m'entraîner puis prendre son humour
pas bon comme ça personne de fonctionner
bien
non c'est dans mes plans justement
j'avais
29 ans qu'il fallait qu'on fixe un
système tout loin et bien d'autres avant
on en reparlera temps d'automne puis
mais c'est mon objet c'est le genre de
cet été de recommencer à plus
m'entraîner tout puisque je le fais pas
moins
pied si je sais ce que je fais pas
d'effort et puis comme un cache plus et
mon corps au pied oui je paye mes stats
depuis je le vois mais moi quand je
m'entraîne
je m'entraîne chez nous
mais
pour moi c'est une forme de méditation
aussi puis on parlais tantôt des
résultats j'aurai de sakhri aujourd'hui
pour vous avez cités nommément c'est un
précieux ticket que je fais le même ton
que je m'entraîne pitch de
la connexion j'ai dans le fond
mentalement ce pas non seulement d'avoir
des miss ne se sent vraiment je me donne
à 100% je suis à la monture ligne puis
quand j'ai fait que c'est que j'avais
cette 10e puis je suis allé à 110% puis
c'est ça sa bosse un peu mal ton
la grèce puis même mentalement notamment
de bien s'entraîner
un joueur qui prendra
21 je m'entraîne 1 1
ça va quoi ajouter notre énorme attend
chaque personne ça va c'est différent
mais j'ai quand même eu huit points
depuis c'est une montagne boisée autour
de dieu mais je fais
tu veux dix mètres le mont split de
tonic gym et ont quand même quand même
temps par jour puis
4-4
mais non je m'entraîne en or en 1 heure
et demie mais dont les fans amassés
comment le sweet spot g j'ai aussi pris
9 physiothérapeute qui viennent déchets
mais fâché au jour de mon mieux ça va
montrer ninja gaiden way parlons tout le
temps
à des citébus 40 au lendemain bah c'est
pas seulement les échos la science a
réussi un temps lorsque ce sur tout à
fait une recherche avant de vie commune
ouais mais c'est que je sais pas s'il
faut l'étudier genre mais c'est que j'ai
vraiment senti la différence idée si je
commence à jouer
12h02 c'est parti je m'étais jamais
vraiment eu à tuer puis
mais mes jambes
ça bouge pour eux c'est comme s'ils
s'étaient même élection 8 points
maintenant fait c'est ce que j'avais un
travail fait j'ai fait trois quatre
semaines puis maintenant montage en fait
une fois c'est même un exercice à deux
exercices parce que je sais que c'est
juste plus humain comme la 1701 1000 wii
points que je trouvais fait j'en fais
deux fois ce n est pas en fait une fois
ces mêmes
360 mais j'ai envie d'enfant le lundi
clou il ya même un super déchets dans le
ton est fâché fax et le fascisme et ma
tante a marre vraiment au mieux c'est
parce qu'elle est mais les systèmes en
tête même si je me sens mais les gens
une foule pompe de la grue qui met les
gens sont hyper restantes sont fortes
mais je ne fais pas expansionnisme
attend la grosseur de taxi que j'avais
senti comme partant dans des squats
l'agencé wam avant avant pas vraiment
bâti
genre quintus quand tu dises squattent
le salève plus humaine que le marché
battait je le sentais m'a pas autant
qu'elles puissent vraiment dur à 100
c'est fait enfin on verra bien qui me
déchirer la membrane qui tout du moins
ce qu'il gardait le muscat et shopi fait
qui a créé la place pour que je puisse
ex-pensionnaires une pompe meudon c'est
un peu ce jour je sens la différence
c'est fou je m'appuie dans l'oeuf en
fait seuls ceux c'est maintenant le
lundi puis de suite après le train du
sud puis ça fait mal en ce moment
les enfants alors à cette info
gisi la réponse
[Musique]
mais
le deux semaines puis des larmes qui
coulaient
mais
je pense quand même c'est pas la fin de
jal mais liverpool c'est jaune c'est
pleurer et associés à un événement que
le monde dispose de coupler le monde se
met à pleurer comme une habitude de
travail ont la cote
puis sans rien après
je fais pas beaucoup de muscu par
exemple je suis pas là pour
plaindre
je parlais des manques étaient comme des
formes et matériaux mobile j'aurai je
savais même pas commander mais ça peut
bouger
je vais distribution réalise damien
jalet 0 grâce à coup sûr découvrir des
sensations que j'aie jamais eue lundi
matin moi parce que mes stages anti
béton à kinshasa bougeait plus c'est
juste c'est comme c'est ici maintenant
c'est comme une espèce de sous et
s'applique aux pièces tout cas pas de
farce ben je voyais pas ma pauvre dame
inspiré comme ce genre s'est arrêté
près de 700 puis je fais beaucoup
d'enfants j'ai mal toute insulte à 2001
si l'on se fonde la caille ce matin
pendant huit heures par jour mais
pendant des années quatre ferries du tas
de cadeaux ça te défoncer d'une de fait
cammas mais ma déchirure c'est une faute
de place nous mettons j'avais même après
deux ans j'avais la grosseur de balles
de golf dans mon chuck et au poignet
mais touche de son époux jean pierre
leleux
disponible à chaque semaine à vienne
face à ces indélicats mac et je me suis
dit ah je veux vraiment gros sabots du
parc les uns mais ces violences et j'ai
comme je peux choisir aussi d'un focus
[Musique]
livres 72 points sensibles puissent pas
de gueule
le plus âgé était c'était 192 à la cei
pour sa joie c'est quand même le rouge
pour 5 et 10 il mijote un poisson de moi
ce qui
m je parlais l'aurait pas c'était trop
genre surtout que c'est comme cela que
mon âge et ce sera plaisant mais l'aigle
effectivement auteuil vacances encore un
peu mais c'est presque manger ce qui
n'améliore explique josette qui
aimeraient en plus honnête l'aide des
jambes ça peut devenir lourde mais j'ai
peut-être 196 derrière des natation puis
je regarde les des photomatons jetez
plus gros score quand même
considérablement puisque le cassant son
bâton mais jean lejarre mes cuisses les
fesses le ton le ndé jeter ute même plus
pour y est elle est là c'est quand même
en course et moi c'est moi
mais c'est
justement d'avoir comme le sacrifice de
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que ça amène le
monde sait aussi les amènent un peu dans
mon johnny passe techniquement mais je
serai petit story pendant je m'entraîne
je me souhaite allonger pas besoin
d'attention ge j'aime pas ça fait
longtemps que j'avais avec quelqu'un qui
te poses la question c'est combien ce
torride fait par jour piloter je serai
pont du leu compte le nombre de story
c'est qu'encore une fois ci c'est le
fait en attendant autres
c'est
le nom que je pense pas mal ça
papote à jour n'a pas la faute aux
[Musique]
pilotes
faut que tu cuse et maintenant
la reprise de fitness plus j'imagine que
c'était moins toi qui cuisinait
le filet
puis le fait que l'auteur commencé à
cuisiner
les coups ce titre les coupes cook
dessus de l'ied non
même
si m des cadets a fait de même
mais c'est pas que je matte a appris des
choses pour mais plus compliqué que ce
sens je supporte pas la capacité
cognitive de poser des codes
maison mais c'est juste des 6 ou 10
mètres focuses on sait ce que ça vaut la
peine que je fasse
ça principales informatrices c'est un
pas que je réfléchissais moins par
rapport à ceux qui m'ont pas aidé un
compteur les défenseurs de cette façon
les habits lui liam fox
c'est bien mais même à faire pour
cuisiner tous
ces sujets par ricardo passeport
je marche pas et et je peux le kilt
reçoit aussi c'est justement le jeu ma
mère j'ai fait mon travail c'est
illimité fixe pas de l'abus mais ces
quatre
solutions netasq répondent soit les gens
ont faim de capitalisme et on est reçu
des instructions de deux regards de
garden hill débat
même côté tatjana malek d'affaires je
veux lavage et maintient maison tout ce
ça me prend moi je trouve pas que ça me
rend folle de tenter un coup de chance à
fond face de la journée
mais
j'ai peu fille le pen ne m'attendais à
voir plus de choses à faire
c'est sûr ça prend un peu plus de tam
et on le sait pas ce qu'elle est je
comprends mieux maintenant si tu fais de
base +1 29 10 par jour ma tente d'en
passer un peu moins gens comme ça que ça
sert à quoi mettre une journée type le
mettant dans la vie de max était mardi
une journée en bas je me lève après
soeur ces dernières
quand tu racontes ajourne à quelqu'un
comme jamais en disant je me lève
non
mais regardez simplement
des fouilles pas si facile pour moi me
réveillais touche trop peu d'entreprises
maroc oui oui mais qu'à compter du matin
à
5h30 on s'est levé à 46 ans il n'y a pas
une fois tu étais facilement bonne tête
en chine sait pas plus sur un drop à ce
que ce genre fallait que ma mère me
force à me lever 10 sport pour l kayaleh
la lte pour moi ces gens là qui lève toi
la 6ème avec toi pour cela il a porté à
tisser entre les points comptés
mais avec tout leur environnement
notamment de son environnement
mais moi si match je sais que je vais me
fatiguer le lendemain mon téléphone j'ai
eu mon téléphone dans ma chambre d'un
malade mais mon alarme si je laisse ma
table de chevet il ya bien des chances
que je peux je peux dire depuis que
georges nous je les mets dans ma salle
de bain avec les sound permettant avant
même des mandats mais je me répète la
parole jean charest qui mon téléphone va
sonner je me lance à la main je m'adonne
en face ces gens je peux georges les
fermes je retourne à mon imac je me
conditionne d'avant sac dès que je me
lève s'il s'agit d'un texte commun gay
j'ai fait et puis juste parce que ça me
réveille ce nom des fois je dormais sur
le toit mais la cac alors tu le mets ton
avis ça dépend des jours ça dépend des
enfants récemment je me lève plus tôt
mais je me couche pas le trim est
idéal malades en une journée
parfaite pour moi mais j'aime me lever
tôt parce que tout le monde dort puis je
me fais pas de stage champeau jeune
prêcheur de soi des répondantes et
répondants nous d'être le politique ou
d'aller au bureau et télé mais je suis
tout le monde l'est seulement deux en
europe ses fonctions au 26 juin font des
premières productions peut-être mais
sinon car je m'adapte le tc cela
supposerait une fois je me lève six mois
avec moi un pied sillage mêmes éléments
les plus secrètes s'est fait une idée
almaraz cat ennemis ces gens là dessus
les gens puis 3 ce matin c'est un petit
fait ce petit couac donne moi c'est pas
trop tu m'agresses parce qu'elle n'était
même plus avec le cirque du soleil
on embarque vers
1h30 la nuit l'un préféré rappeler ce
qu'il fait bon bataille playskool tonka
fait c'est même s'ils coûtent on estime
en allemagne et une heure et demie de
l'annuaire interne en mousse un peu mais
je pense qu'ils se parce qu'il ya quand
même un projet les qu'il faut qu'ils
travaillent soient levées nuit j'arrive
à un live sur facebook à 1h30 la nuit
puis c'est pas parce qu'ils ont tort ni
juste de bonnes
finances accusé mme byrs c'est en live
vient pas de personne qui va poser des
questions
la haye qui tombait dans le chat
aussi c'est des fois ça peut être si si
le monde politique mais propose des gens
d'affaires comme si c'est maintenant
j'ai peut-être françois avard dessine de
ces conditions j'ai dit comme je ferai
ce que ça m'a aidé à puis le
jeu se
met finalement tu veux avoir consommé en
disant que 2 heures du matin jamais
désormais ça c'est ton terme si tu veux
récupérer le plus fac ce matin
d'ailleurs il faut chaque rider heures
de sommeil a cédé peu sacrifié dans
cette mine de le passer le bonjour puis
chaque académie c'est ce genre mon idée
a autant de mal vu puis je commence à
faire de quoi qui s'imposent cinquième
mois qu'ils peuvent ou ne peuvent pas de
courriels des touches d'avancé gens
vraiment difficile puisque créatif que
j'ai besoin d'un traitement par un
mental parce que plus que la journée
avance puisque tu des ménages un peu le
ton ton attention plutôt facile de mon
attention était atteint son pic pijper
bon
24 heures parce que tout ennemi
après sa chute avec la môme plus plus
président solving dans l'es10 puis
fait qu'avancer prévoit du temps juste
pour qu'on
réfléchira qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on se
croit prochaine à faire qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est quoi qui est qu'elle se dit
qu'ils viennent nous allons chez les ch
et des meilleures saisons j'ai douté
s'appuie si souvent j'ai l'impression le
ce qu'on veut couper comme moi je sais
qui est période où est ce que j'ai
vraiment la joe bar fabb petit truc
éthique que j'ai juste une styliste de
tâches plus faux que les façons après
l'autre il faut que je rate faut que je
rende ce que je livre la marchandise
mais dont si ces moments là que j'ai pu
mais ton juste au moment exact à qui
c'est quoi que j'invite pas ce que j'ai
envie de créer c'est quoi que je t'ai de
laisser les idées montait un peu
l'inspiration plessé genre justement
s'inspirer tchéquie de l'affairé curieux
puis c'est comme le plus c'est la
première s'est pas fait que ça va c'est
ce qui donne une sélection psychiatre
ajouté ces mots si on utilise le tous
les matchs du jour 2b de steam puis tout
le team est honteux d'un projet et puis
même avis le ma vie et dans les cups
c'est fou tout est dedans facile pendant
que les clubs ça à la panique mais le
pape k6 de la clippers et
le samedi dimanche et 1 heure à chaque
jour que je sais juste du learning
fruits j'en sais pas de quoi qui est
spécifique mathon par rapport à un
déjeuner sous par rapport de coty faut
que je fasse je prends alors que la
fraction nombreux
partis sur des articles sur les lieux de
vidéo n'est pas très commun c'est comme
un autre genre mais il s'y ajoute
metering sofia
jazz et le petit sketch pas ce site site
sera en mauvaise mais qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire en une journée c'est de moi
mais en général tu peux faire deux
choses qui me line folle quête peu
mouffe ton projet fort de ce que ce soit
en développement personnel ou que ça
soit tu as besoin d un succès soit et je
sais pas n'importe comment c'est
vraiment juste deux choses on est plus
forts un beau trou si il était une fois
m pas vraiment faire puisque ce fait
tout les reste souvent c c'est une
heureuse il était obligé de donner de
l'eau chaude en post séance à [ __ ]
face mais sinon général
c'est ce que j'essaie de ctg
j'ai une question par rapport à ça parce
que ben parle pas je sais combien de
temps avant qu'un jeu postale et aller
ailleurs mais
mettant d'autre qu'un con qu'un comprend
une pause puis qu'on se demande c'est
quoi le prochain projet maintenant
toutes les fois où est ce qu'on a fait
ce on a lancé on a mis le pied vers le
prochain projet
dans les semaines qui ont suivi tu sais
mais ça arrive souvent qu'on est comme
j'ai pas deux trois mois un but en
dehors des toits à ne pas dire c'est
quoi le prochain projet est à nouveau
posée à agir comme rouler ou genre
continuer dans le statut cours maintenon
puis j'imagine que dans nos vies
personnelles autant que dans les
différentes business
de penser à ckoi le prochain le next ap
c'est vraiment important puis je
voudrais entendre là dessus à savoir
est ce que toi tu es dans ta tête
mettons un pas je n'aime pas
l'expression end gaulle un but final
parce que ça existe on en avait parlé le
prévenu n'était pas défini la mairie met
ainsi tout le temps en arrière tat est
un genre de but autant pour toi que pour
tes business puisque quand vient le
temps de d'avoir ces périodes-là jeu
demain comme on parlait le titre de
canetons quatre heures de début que
juste toi tu peux mourir un verre un
objectif d capable de plus facilement
farouk et si l'objectif est là c'est
quoi le la marche nous y aller non ce
jeu les sims à mende il n'y a pas de
gosses et
comme un sprinteur comme défense de deux
ans souvent car je souhaitais maintenant
malfi gt2 en amont serait créé mon site
te dit jean jé période on n'a presque
pas tous ces cinq hommes des colis c'est
un mauvais pour tout plu au projet j'ai
fait puis le facteur ça reste que céder
si c'était un finish line mais par
rapport au projet ou par rapport à
l'objectif selon météo france
j'attends un cycle accroissent aussi
c'est grâce à nous
fister pas c'est que ce nouveau
moustique soir comac ceci aussi que je
vais améliorer parce que j'avais
beaucoup d'enfants dans ma tête me
tourne j'en ai beaucoup j'ai écrit mais
jay hill de verbaliser mathon asseoir
mon partenaire ou à 9 heures avant les
témoins de même la maintenance et plus
clown en 6ème étape c'est ok sinon y'a
bon livre là-dessus c'est majeur est
malheureuse de jendouba
concernant ben c'est la façon comment
écrire tes objectifs puis qui était
objectif soit bien vécu véhicules et
puis mesurable mais de plusieurs sortes
d'objets cultes et des méthodes et
épique que tu dis je
mais ces gens l'aient le sexy money and
gold c'est ces gens c'est plus un
feeling et zoumana de dire on a même le
projet à telle place par ces outils de
voix dans le futur puis après c'était
tous des objectifs maintenant les mêmes
parcours européen peu importe qu est ce
qui marchait tout simplement suivre ça
peut être sympa mais qui est un objectif
tanin plus gros plat c'est tout
mais tout est petit mason fonctionne
mesurables et quantifiables singes
magots loin pas sinon c'est dur de
savoir si on les laisse qu'on leur
rappelle c'est exact c'est vraiment plus
simple à elle vu qu'il est à l'équipe
pour tout le monde puis le monde sic
ainsi défini c'est vraiment mieux le
pilote sur la gym
le monde isa j'aimerais sûr
j'aimerais savoir si m6 0 définitive y
ajoute l auto
c'est quoi ça le seco temps comme state
est tombé en disgrâce après un bond de
la mta way selon le monde il fait juste
la gaule j'aimerais savoir des médias
pas mesurable rien de savoir je peux
vraiment le projet semaines de révolte
mais ça m'a fada c'est
ce que tu dis là
parce qu'effectivement
si tu dirais je me rends delà de toutes
les maisons mais les milestones les mac
sont que ce même pas s'écarter pourrait
se passer quand tu finis ton et tapis
parce que comment tu veux commencer
l'autre d'après ce qui s'est passé quand
tu as fini celle là dessus
ça donne de l'énergie aussi tu t'es
juste avoir une idée qui flotte dans ta
tête à place d'avoir une des kits à tai
chi qui est établi de foi qui une fois
qu'on frappe ce secteur nous intime du
même travail intime ou pas les peurs ses
partenaires la tan un kinder concernant
les prochaines c'est quand est ce que
c'est mais si tout est clair d'après
c'est bien plus facile depuis lors
personne veut dire je peux t'aider
là-dessus gens m'attendent parce qu'ils
savent à se mettre ces c'est quoi les
legault se situait j'essaie de plus
comme des célébrer les succès selon m
enjoy plus sur le passé je son équipier
onex passé way par défaut je tout
phoenix mais enfin mais dans une pièce
qui étudiait faut qu'on fasse un jour
juste la forêt puis après ce qu'ils
coûtent nex 1 mais genre de plus plus ça
va plus que jeune justin
sa folie samsung l'est
c'est ça de la reconnaissance mais aussi
de la direction c'est là qu'on sent vote
c'est subtil en plus comme souvent on
pense que ces différences maintenance et
subtilité comme ça fait dix ans que
c'est vraiment ça a été développé m lien
ce qui nous écoute on essaiera de le
partager c'est sa partie des enfants et
des six autres intel malta qui
utilisaient ces îles comme écrit un
livre là-dessus les gens piste est comme
ces princes et peut-être que lyon comme
bordeaux n'a plus joué depuis
google est bannie des compagnies qui
utilisent ces jusqu'à plus simple pour
des grosses thèmes aussi mais même pour
des plus petites équipes ou même toi
personnellement deux titres étaient ok
âge puis la façon que tu formule des
hockeyeuses
inconsciemment ça va aller cette chipie
ça t'enlève sous la pression de jeu one
méga giga to do this way puis des fois
tu nous lis mais tu as tu du lycée mixte
point la forêt c'est juste des idées est
annexée c'est pas de concret plutôt qu'à
battre deux fois de faire assez pour
qu'on fait sur ce que ça va m'emmener
vraiment voir le big bang my 4 une bonne
session petit lac issyk ou qu'on fait +
tous les crimes et tous ces gens les
liens entre chacun des objectifs que le
jusqu'à écrire ce qu'ils ont fait ce
lieu non ça va c'est pas trop
personnel justement quantité mais tant
qu'ils m'ont vu ses avoirs étaient
jean-rameau bus et la chaîne maison mais
ces quelques mots ont été dits légaux
remettons je plaisantais petit 7 h 30 au
cégep à musique donc moins de temps puis
que je veux
je jouis la compagnie d'artistes et
brille en attente c'est le hand ball
mais genre ça peut paraître complètement
impossible puisque jamais ça va arriver
sauf que si le québec faut que je prenne
un premier contrôle il faut que j'arrive
tel niveau
tant pis si ce qui finalement ça rend le
l'impossible
ça fait aussi penser à ça s'appelle
rivers ingénieurs jacky mascelli qu'on
va aller bosser quoi de commun qu'on
sera comment construire le tuf et toute
la liste la précède sur la liste comme
alors c'est peut-être pour ça me titille
pitch tout est également qui est mon
mail est quelqu'un qui va nous amener en
externe ça marche vraiment
sympathique mais puis souvent même tu
sais si ma tante se disait qu'ils
étaient trop step web seront peut-être
trop le monde c'est faux il faut que je
sache la stap rendre jaloux cette bulle
mais si c'est des gestes trop peut-être
au stade dr sadi était bon ou peut-être
déjà fils de tito step 3 parce que ça va
aider à accomplir les steppes de
danse step 3 finalement c'est un steve
deux
berlines deux directions en même temps
mais si tu l'établi pas tu le sais pas
si je fais tu ici ou temps c'est simple
on peut seulement ils font juste
possible
99% soin de composer un déclin tu fais
tout autant
du côté business qui est attaquée
personnellement
je me demande mon jogging c'était pour
moi c'est mon objectif que les jeunes
notables chefs appris de mon premier
gros c'est le revenant chez l'as passage
et bien d'autres fonctionnalités
courir un marathon
qu'un dj
sport l'or comme des kilomètres assez
surpasser les quelques
clichés match et je
sais je je pense que tu suis le nick
berg
supplément
du coup tu le connais plus personne non
je gagne évoqué puis à lui ya participé
c'est un bon craquer les filles est
parti il ya fait le led by one hundred
ses 1 100 miles qui est en 60 kg dessus
mais il est arrivé il l'a fait venir
toute son équipe type qui a fait
déplacer toute l'équipe de bpn pour
faire d'eux les stations de
ravitaillement a amené genre quatre
grades de vie des vidéastes
elle a aussi amené tout le monde mais
que toute son équipe que louer un gros
et ça a dû coûter man la sphère de genre
sa gamme de bias le faire venir tout le
monde pour filmer sur l'été
puis pour avoir essayé des 81 kg puis je
suis pas mal plus léger que lui puis
genre installé google ouvre un training
qui est comme semblable
il réussit à se rendre aux 160 km mais
c'est après 30 heures il comme arrivé
après l'air après la date limite que tu
peux leur limite le trépassé le thème
sauf que il ya les pop il pouvait pas
abandonner le basque avait tellement
investi ce genre d'argent des vidéastes
sur le voit des foyers genre et comme
ils ont filmé en pleine de la nuit et du
moment que c'est comme la deuxième nuit
le fait que quand on fait deux nuits
déjà y arrête eacom de boucles il ya
comme un gars côté vue qui est un de ses
amis qui comme ce pêcheur pour pour
l'aider le tu le voyais même
plus rien dire
pied devant l'autre
mais tu apprends imagine utiliser
le cas je me suis jamais très loin
moratoire longe écuries se disent que
l'on puisse tester sur un bout de moi
seule la dystromarche se charge le matin
jusqu'en coups soit
sept kilos à québec marathon pied qu'un
que je l'avais trouvé avec 4 puis je le
faire le demi marathon j'ai approché en
continu du gers à ce jour ça va
peut-être plus tôt je te voyais aussi de
s'arrêter au lac léman depuis trois mois
le cas cette année là c'était mon
premier marathon
mais je veux juste lève toi tu es
vraiment pas une course je vais me lever
un matin puis on court le 42e puis si je
marche à la fin aujourd'hui mais je le
fais des gens puis si j'ai après
quarante deux cas moi je peux continuer
je me sens pas continuer
[Rires]
c'est riou tomb raider 3h 4h ou à la
ville
de couëron l'exemple tecomah à moi je
peins être le terrain qui sont
fonctionnaires subalternes jamais caché
pour les voeux pointé la main que le
secourir jean sa foule fallait pour les
autres on s'enfonce encore cette lettre
vous êtes un athlète juste bouger voire
fait juste essayer
le site marchand
justement des figurines ou début juin un
marché de marigot
puissante machine le maillage is over
time mais il ya comme a pris justement
lui qui était il faut te sacrifier chose
puis servait en méditation sellem seul
mauvais mashhad dans le nord-est
multimédia mais si tel hamza à rester
assez bien t comme un fou je médite
lycée stress parce qu'ils se trouvent
qu'ils me disent tous option peu capable
de
bien que j'ai fait de la musique et je
vais tourner avec lui je ne connaissais
pas avant pis j'en ris plus jolie dont
45-50 cpie cigolotti l'a vraiment à
chier playtv revendiquent tous tes nerfs
free to make nerf et c'est là vraiment
en forme
il me dit que thil depuis deux mois va
comme une joie des crises existentielles
puis j'en riais les sablons depuis
janvier en fait les petits cochons ce
qui rend le point sur sa vie t il dit
c'est une démarche est ici je marche 20
à 30 kilomètres par jour c'est fou c'est
le 20 à 30 kilomètres par jour se lève
le matin
vos marchés doit les marchés genre n 10
kg rien chez origin fait d'autre à faire
ton marché les mesures nécessaires mais
ma maman je t'aime j'habite à une
pression l'argent puis le samedi chaque
matin dans la commune façon dont il mène
déjà 2 machines de trois des six essais
toutefois king sharing marché pigeât
beaucoup d' excuses dans toutes nos
problèmes je fais tout
en marchant gérer toutes les affaires du
couple musique de paris c'est quoi
puis-je semaine dijon jettera mieux que
ça change et ça
jccm le témoin quand leur équipe htc
s'écroule c'est juste toi puis tous ceux
qui malades de l'entraînement aux justes
de bouger en général c'est fou quatre
sites ont atteint à peine cuivre
intérieure
celle un mois maintenant je vais courir
en forêt maintenant depuis quand je
courais en faudrait quatre courses à moi
je mets de la musique ou des podcasts
2015 à courir en forêt entre elles puis
pillowman
select ou même pendant l'un des buts
était le temps de régler des démons
parler d'andré clé des instants passé à
oui qu'en plus tu penses d'une place
c'est que t4 bourges les surréalistes et
maîtresses muscles de l'été juste mieux
les jouer c'est le monde peut faire le
test ci il parle live qui ont pas obligé
d'ajouter que les lits font juste
débauche bout d'histoire place et il se
met à parler c'est déjà deux personnes
totalement différente moi je file cnrj
de
quantifier ce dégel s est levé lis déjà
plein d'argent mais c'est un désarroi
qui manquait le plus c'est le feeling de
juste montrer ni d'amazon mais
aussi
comme
dans tous les styles avec
analyse ça vient d'un peu de positif ne
s'est jamais plaint et puis je me dis ah
juste après quelqu'un mais ce matin en
asie s'il ya tellement d'enfants qui se
passe dans ta temps éclipsé les solides
par des conversations octobre il y en
avoir mais parce qu'ils font c'est qui
qui veut même sur la barre de
ma vie que je sache je me voyais tout de
même quand j'étais jeune je suis pas
l'atteindre personnes face et puis
là-bas à part mehdi mettant fin aux
disparités est pas grave oui mais
l'objectif de méditer ces deux points
c'est de vider complètement toi mais moi
si c'est que tu sur
réfléchissez quand même être celle faire
de tes pensées et puis de seulement tout
ce que je lis votre ensemble et ça peut
être un peu ce déficit est allemande
puis le nom c'est un objectif mais c'est
vraiment de je trouve que quand tu es
déjà serveur web 2 com est-ce que tu
files depuis quand est ce que tu penses
tu es capable de dire ce que je viens de
dire complètement rome puis j'oublie
m'excusent les jeux où elle demandé à ce
que je trouve ce qui est justement vous
du jour un pote c'est ici half hour
beaucoup de monde va passer enfin webcam
est dit et ça les ied elle sait faire
parce que le gosse est de savoir de
fixer soir point où quelque chose puis
quand tu dévider dur de savoir que des
vigies cécé loua le fond c'est de penser
que si j'allais acheter pour les
opérations on le sait un peu plus mais
la france que tu fais city fait juste
développer faut qu'ils le font dans un
sens
c'est un bon exercice mais si tu fais un
peu directement celui qui veut donner
des bons bénéfices s'entraîner puis
bouger ça t'amène à prévoir cet achat
d'entraîneur isotopes ça fait juste de
vox et surtout
me catherine oger
bas souvent oui mais mais ont maintenant
un stade su s'était pas autant qu'il
faisait de la vie aux quatre ans
maintenant
réparé dès que je la fasse que c'est
comme si les gens de rares moments parce
qu'ils étaient vraiment comme est dans
le moment présent pitié pas de
distractions puis quand rien d'autre
vraiment juste le
scoci a beau se
hisse il manquait un moment
d'introspection femmes
non seulement
tout eu
là ça fait vraiment longtemps que je
t'aime venu chez vous pouvez montrer les
plaint du plus gros projet d'avis
pas trop sauf que
dis moi ce que tu peux me dire sur ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis je
pense à fait on était venu chez vous pas
longtemps après impôts de gascon avait
fait doux avant mais puis je pense à
l'après midi ça fait savoir le tchèque
qui s'était l'épisode 3
points intéressants
mais c'était un des plus gros
mais
ça a été ça n'est pas une fois c'était
pendant les deux années plus de deux
mille dix nations il par rapport à ça
pour ce projet le
tas parce qu'il y
en a plein d'autres à faire que jeu se
met ce matin côté niveau stress piteux
picot télé le risque de l'os les
sept chiffres wait and see
parce que vous parce qu'ils étaient
commencés le projet moi c'est ce qui
s'est passé de courage ce jeu j'en parle
plus je
[Musique]
dis poitiers devance de plus de 500 kg
de cannabis à nador tickets c'est que je
puisse y ait quelque chose qui était
revenu ce week-end devant la laverie
cause alpine s'acquiert pas ce que je
dirais avec ses pieds toutes les
directions
ça prend un méchant beauty ont poussé
mais la cantine zec ce matin coincé
c'est déjà on a eu le goût auquel on
peut tout arrêter et puis
bientôt le monde qui nous écoutent vont
pouvoir savoir de cause
failli chier parce que pour avoir vu les
des balbutiements de soucis
c'est vraiment une passion c'est
d'accueil tu m'as tu vois pas
normalement si je reste
je peux pas je peux pas
sa fiche ils
ont fait 1,5 ou 2 impose tout est ce qui
est ce qu il a crevé de jouer là dedans
c'est s'est pour sa part c'est sûr que
le supply chain les prix
d afrique et
construit mais tôt ou tard
de m on parle de tout le concept de ce
projet était déjà tombée au pire on est
là dessus sur un bouton ouais ok mais
elle est encore mieux j'ai montré que
j'étais venu pour
ça
[Musique]
pour le meilleur capable est ce que tu
peux dire maintenant dans quelques jours
d'horizon fissurer on peut voir ces
maisons
c'est un début d'émeute on trouve un
petit peu après l'annoncé de sa majorité
commencent à fumer des biens dessine
tout en fait c'est ce qu'on a fait enfin
je sais pas quand est ce qu'on va
laisser la place à ce qu'on comprend
c'est bien quand on présente mais de ça
commence
dans trois semaines john terry belton
coupure doit être
trop hier parce que
juste à temps
on faisait la critique de ta journée
puis on arrêtait
bonne journée toutes les quatre heures
et demie traitons quatre heures plus de
créations nouveau bureau s'il était plus
dans la gestion plus
le team les rides et les arbitres ou des
doges plus plus routinières s'est
jusqu'à maintenant
le récemment ça change un peu de ce
majeur je porte mais justement parce que
je me faisais même à ses pieds marché
mais le fait que je me fais masser à
cinq
hommes 5 1 puis je me faisais mon
training passagère travail franchement
je travaille jusqu'à
cette séance de travail
c'est drogba c'est juste une
continuation de ce que j'ai fait le
matin pascal couraud piste
mais voilà parce que j'ai besoin de
faire le cinéma
fait je continue quand même mais sinon
elle va maintenant je peux peut-être du
bureau plus verts cécile mi7 je faisais
parfois j'avais une blanche
mais bien parce que j'avais une
situation de ce genre pour sept ans avec
dès
[Musique]
maintenant
les trucs que tu vas apprendre pas
par curiosité personnelle ou par juste
les skieuses que tu apprends pas cet
intérêt soirée vers quoi rentrer là
dedans c'est externe où l'on est obligé
que ça j'ai maintenant des space les
agents cet argent que je me tais tu sais
quoi parce que dans ta toutes ses ventes
à 2
c max nous dit-on pas cela
vraiment ce moment ça fait du bien comme
il faut vraiment qu'ils se connectent
pigeon c'est un méditation je reprends
ta deux scénaristes mais moi cela je
dois mettre déjà l'audiobook la fin je
me lève je te le dis aux bouclettes
institution qui a fait tous
[Musique]
les matins je mange plancher mais
maintenant le soir là ses quatre usines
saison ma main pour faire autre chose
j'écoutais quand
on gère ce moment là ma journée c'est
maximiser
pascal ivanovic et cet habitant gens
remplissent tous les critères pour une
20e 1.10
makanda de ce type ce moment là
c'était notamment trop points 50 juste
lui le que ceux-ci m'attends juste ton
voiturage situe fin de la route n'était
pas un acte encore plus récemment jean
kuete deux semaines enchaîné olive s'il
écoute je m'attends toujours bas 26
livres par année
jeu bon ça fout la casse en face il
expliqué quand je dis agen 10 1 avec 40
il perd son temps arrive 0 1 c'est juste
lipse
va céder fois je vais écouter souvent
que la musique ne met la musique et je
dis que c'est tout par rapport à un mood
ou un style je m'attends quand on décide
de sortir mais je repense à ma mère en
audio books intéressant vallée ousse et
consorts gens
disent pas tout âge
c'était quelqu'un piloter
au box comment naissent à la croissance
comme trois personnes encore un peu
chaude
on a dit
[Rires]
non merci et lui tous ces moments si
j'ai pas eu le plaisir de lire mais si
ça n'arrive que ça me donne faim contact
humain qui satisfait toutes les teintes
investit aussi dans son développement
personnel y sera ajouté laura convient
d'éviter que j'apprends salle pendant un
à reims et c'est fou ça des fois c'est
même pas
des feuilles veulent vraiment comme
phase active learning fax est vraiment
concentré là-dessus à prendre je prends
foule de notes
moi ce que je fais si juge la rendent à
moi mais des fois je pense une course
puis je continue mon aux yeux bleus ben
chef des despotes puis si j'ai des notes
que je vais prendre part à voir sa
chemise parce qu'ils sont servis que
près d'un accord que ça
s'appelle l'extrait du podcast pagny
c'est elle mais à soignies cris ou mais
c'est le seul vendeur mais je focus sur
l'ativité qu'ai-je fait je crois c'est
intéressant ça que j'essaye puis après
ce bel âge un procès ce que mme à une
box un peuple j'y retourne toujours
passé a fallu que je peux prendre par
rapport au message veut le faire cela
maintenant la fin des fois je peux le
faire une fois par mois j'en reprends
ses stocks mais mais ça y va c'est un
matériel prêté grande attraction qui
fait les arrêts qu'il fallait c'est pas
le monde voit ses commettants jean teulé
puisque m'a fauché apprennent que le
chemin soit plus que ce mot c'est moins
de monde le sait vraiment plus j'essaie
de tout ce qui s'est passé
très vite hadja petit seul dans ton
genre tu fais écouter la radio tchèque
écouter la même musique à nos attentes a
connu j'ai
compris à moins qu'hier il faut vraiment
et c'est parce qu'il faut justement
cette année nous ça fait vraiment du
bien pour le we walk étape a rapporté
qu'au moins ces world mais moi je me
pose quand même la question hockey soit
ce que j'écoute pas l'audiobook porte
couleurs puis souvent même des des
livres que j'ai cru que c'était par
rapport à qu'est ce que je vis dans le
moment où deux quoique jours à apprendre
des fois c'est même pas avant que je
connais pas toutes les concepts on a
parlé avant le pottier c'est juste des
petits merci dans lé top et 2 décès aux
deux côtés exemple d'écouter ender de
cameron qui courait un peu comme des
figurines larcher
n'a été que de son livre lui il dit tout
histoires aux gens qui comme acquis
terreur depuis juin
soit juste une machine jamais tu
écoutais suisse et ses 8 après certains
concepts stores août mais c'est plus
vraiment la marque
commencera à neiger peut-être plus afin
d'en manger j'ai remis mes temps d autun
a bondi à
l'étranger qu'au départ c'est vraiment
un bon l'insee je te parle je travaille
depuis six rencontres c'est tout le
monde
c'est normal
que les gens parce que le premier pack
est ce qu'on avait fait avec toi les
gens avaient le même commentaire avait
le même feeling après l'avoir écouté que
nous on avait en surtemps moi je me
rappelle on est allés manger au lof
à laval puis après se jeta les cours est
en demi marathon sur un tapis roulant en
revenant qui était quand même temps les
genres mais j'étais trop craint que les
troquer puis le monde avait le même
feeling en sorte instructif et que c'est
vrai que les conversations de mettre
dans le doute le témoin là en ce moment
j'ai envie d'aller prendre un white
bourde de genre tracé le plan pour les
cinq prochaines années puis j'ai
l'impression que le monde ça va leur
faire son petit d'écouté sur fait que si
vous commandez fois justement juste
entendre la répétition puis des fois on
a tendance à perdre et affable c'est
fait maintenant c'est le chemin qui
borde le jeu va craquer demain j'aurais
craqué après demain sa semaine notons
cette conversation loeb ce feeling
l'objet suppose au fossoyeur john ça
s'essouffle un petit peu oui si tu la
mets
cette conversation
mais réécouter de quoi être satisfait
ses supporteurs craquer tout le temps ce
genre juste comme je tête dose ou juste
rappeler des affaires que tu sais
en place des trucs pour hier pour les
atteindre
maître quinquis et comme
motivation des parties de hockey
ça c'est tout un temps fou comme
transformer les célébrations des ti
lapointe qui tourne dans laquelle en
double ils font tout au plus à faire
craquer la tête du lycée le régime afin
qu'ils cessent à la sauce ketchup aucun
cas je puis pendant que tu écris
inquiétudes il va je sais que je vois
des moments que je veux je souhaite moi
ceux qui s'intéressent à celle ci se
fait l'affairé samedi dimanche et mon
learning tout c'est par rapport à ce
décret qui
explose l'exploit
comment se présente
pas souvent que l'on peut entendre - qui
aime tant
les humains on va faire les listes on
peut faire je survis on veut conserver
notre énergie puis un précieux répit
sinon je mettrais ce que je pense que
madame est restée faible l'environnement
comme la fin du cadran la plus loin si
c'est ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut mais
tu le fait d'une place conscient que le
sergent parce que si tu on est 90% de
journée aujourd'hui habité juste fait
ce petit parti comme chauffer pour elle
une telle place pour lui à votre liste
mais jean qu'un petit risque et john
peut-être mal pourquoi je me force ou
kde su y en est là il faisait aussi même
sur tout autre genre il ya maintenant
des objectifs maintenant juge mal à
vacarme et avait twitté des sketches
drôles pour être postés lester des coûts
et mathon poinat machine folle route
j'arrive wasyl maghreb
à cinq cordes en la matière
[Rires]
et
je souhaite en panne de courant
et donner le temps à des affectifs
oui ça va ça me de coûts à telle
personne où
il se lève pas
le pied mais ils vont être à la fois
riche et si je peux peut-être a connu
une semaine ne pas citer le foot et
enfin oui 90km au lac-saint-jean qui m'a
ballack puis jetée entraîné pour un 100
m dos la semaine avant exigeant un
effort de 50 ça me prenait 7 à 9 55
secondes versus un effort de 2 heures
que je ne peux pas tout dans ma maison
j'espère m'en sors qu'il planchait le
financeur à savais que j'étais pas
entraîner pas en tout pour ça qu'on est
jamais vouloir arrêter puis comment ça
marche qui a une chaloupe qui te suit
quand tu nages pour te donner des
ravitaillements de l'est de l'autre la
faune sûr que si tu prends la chaloupe
des disqualifiés de valois de taille du
pacha le projet du pont neuf heures sur
bois sur la save à la chaloupe a mené je
commençais à être complètement défoncée
vers 7 kg matches de deuxième mais
georges talibane trouver goethe est
parti bien trop vite c'était vraiment
lui je commençais à crampes et partout
puis je voulais arrêter ma soeur l'a dit
au chauffeur qui conduisait achats le
diwan toit puis là je suis venu pour
voiliers à celle de la chaleur de pulls
la soirée dimanche à des lobala ma soeur
maria qu'elle soit enfin dans l'eau
genre tu es dans l'eau avec soutine ans
jusque jusqu'à alarie la rive by the way
c'est l'arrivée tu vas me dit on dise
clairement quand valentino là où soit
dit noah et arrête de manger une
question de faire la main j'ai fait
georges tin tam art mais ça ça veut dire
d'énergie se serait finalement carton
alors maintenant fini le truc j'ai pas
fait super bon parce que j'ai cassé que
j'étais j'ai explosé sauf qu'ils crient
c'est fini c'était content de l'avoir
fini par et de la volaille et enfin
j'étais plus fort chez commun son
argent
d'avoir fini le truc des offres que j'ai
passé à travers d'adversité et puis si
je mettais trop sté j'aurais team ce
masseur mavs est resté j'aurais prégnant
chaloupe puis j'aurais pas fini le 10
mai j'étais capable de le faire y'avait
pas fini par je n'avais pas le choix ça
me constituer un signe qu'ils essaient
d'y
exemple mais c'était d'autant plus la
gueule
newborn you want you back my name of
fact is it arrive en place pour jeter
les bateaux de pêche est
implanté
c'est un peu ça le concept genre
dramatique ancien parce qu'on y est on
est vraiment étudié de plus en plus fort
mentalement mais c'est un exercice
laisse comme un autre musée dédié à la
musique même car je m'entraîne je suis
ta isi ici les mêmes que c'est dur je me
contente quand même entre un
tout petit
je l'emmenais temps tous écrits mettant
la motivation est toujours là le sport
tous les partis sauf cas précis c'est
transformé sa habite dans le fond tout
ce qui est tout à fait insolite
celui long terme la chose qui est aimé
ton au dessus qui sont vraiment
maintenant je peux me mettre au milieu
que je connais qui est plus la musique
c'est ce qu'ils sont vraiment bons
ils font la musique et ce matin au soir
je réponds c'est pis ça devient leur vie
puis sais même plus ce même puis
ghislaine qu'il est mort aujourd'hui
faut faire de la musique c'est juste
c'est ce qu'ils font qu'imiter justement
dit tantôt je parlais du but au cégep ou
est-ce que je j'ai vraiment fait un
blitz de pratique c'est que maintenant
je fais plus maintenant je prête plus la
guitare est presque pauvreté après qu'un
juste besoin peau en arrivant dès que je
vais apprendre quelque chose de précis
mais juste comme vouloir les graines de
s'améliorer parce que parce
qu'aujourd'hui je met plus d'âme on a
caché aux cégeps et comme tout le temps
que j'avais des livres je me plais ne
fait rien
j'allais au cégep le matin j'arrive à
celle de la normalité je partais à 9
puis tout le temps qui me touchait pas
assez dans un écho chez eux
sur le long terme si tu rends pas compte
des personnes
six mois plus tard
parce que
comme je
craque et je vais vous faire ceci il va
atteindre cet objectif lui sauf que tous
les corps portent pas d'avis mais
finalement
c'est vraiment un
peu ce qu'il faut qui à chaque matin
chaque son est écrit des objectifs puis
pourquoi de feu
c'est ça que ça prend ça s'apprend s'il
faut écrire la même orbite est cinquante
fois chaque jour pour que ça dans ta
petite erreur se saisit d'un bain fait
il ya pas de chaîne
c'est vraiment parce qu'on compte elle
met toute sa
vie si tu sais pas belle et bum et
épices ou software pour ces questions
nous fait juste regarder dans numéro
rapide pour cette question je
l'avais dit de notre jack kante la
famille et puis c'est aussi le fondateur
de
[Musique]
wilileaks marotte et puis il y aura
commencé plus d'accès sur instagram puis
tente encore de rire le
motivationnelle maton
qui j'aurais dit
vous étiez pour atteindre des objectifs
ce qui est tough c'est pas de
si peu de focus sur une chose c'est de
pau focus sur les autres choisies dans
la vie au père avec son arme et on sait
pas avoir une liste de priorités un
ravin et puis ils vont elles sont
valables les vins sont non seulement
vous dire la peine que tu médites en
dedans sauf d'être capable de juste
focus et sur 1 pi 2 po focus sur trop
avant que son ou s'il tenait ce qui
pourrait très bien décider d'investir
ton temps là dedans
c'est oft qui les trucs intéressants des
trucs qui tout je dis non a rejeté des
offres dire non mais je dis de la fa qui
sont aussi cool pour faire les 1 et 2
août libre et même des fois c'est aussi
ce genre sinon qu'ils ont fait subir à
ce jeu tout se met dans ton temps
commence à manquer chez madame de s'ils
font peut-être pas partie de ces étapes
live
je sais plus tard pied je veux tout
risque
54 philbrick demander combien de temps
ça prendra
quand le foot face du monde qui s'est
passé puis même souvent le jeu soit un
backlog de toutes les idées gens qui
sont juste un tout petit pense plus
actives 3d mais c'est ça qui ont été
dites et je trouve c'est une des
affaires qui sont le t4 décider de
décider de décider de décider puis ça
fait juste prendre l'espace mental
serait justement de l'énergie aussi de
penser à ce que je lis drapée sur une
page puis
l'autre comme dans road map et leur
piteux même plus besoin de penser à ce
qu'il a fait que ça prend place ça prend
place puis aussi les humains en iran
avant à quantifier en termes de genre
style de sa grosseur ou pour autant de
céder à québec ceci plus psyché mon
chèque rejoint fallait repasser
capitaliste et voit tout m'était n'y a
pas de vrai en plus les rings kg par
rapport à laruns pas qu'ils vont avoir
remettons je sais qu'on n'est pas que
sur 10 m seulement après ceux qui vont
aussi quoi l'effort que ça prend c'est
le terrain qui l'a précédé sorte de
tabou peu importe le titre a contacté se
farcissent réseau trouve assez sympa qui
est vraiment au fait mais le monde ils
font pas ces gens et oui ils font pas
les pour des chats capable de bien des
critères mais moi je trouve que et fort
impact puis
vint le jour dès maintenant moi je peux
musiciens sont arrivés le matin sous la
premier temps la pendjari peut-être le
plus vieux camp
david il m'était jamais donné mission de
gérer séparément mais c'est quoi
peut-être que je veux jamais ça peut
faire partie déjà mais by one day the
way you lie le système
c'est quoi l'hiver sting donne
un bon lycée justement passé par rapport
à certains une box petit écriteau test
de toutes qu'est ce qui vient tout seul
tout le temps tout est de la faute des
procédés commenté derek joe dante a dit
expliquant que les apc me wade ou ou ac
c'est une ressource pour plus tard où
ceux-ci de quoi que je rende
éventuellement petite béatrice mais au
moins c'était plus besoin de la voix
dans sa tête j'adore voir décrit par
hasard c'est vrai je la prends ce qui
est déjà fait comme d'élite est accordée
mental ça vient juste de créer plus de
places parce
que c'est le chômage
chômage et de réfléchir c'est une manne
qui n'avait ni fonctionner obsidian
links ouais c'est que non non mais moi
quand on se rappelle des enfants et
c'est pas qu'on se rappelle de la chose
c'est qu'ils aient toutes les
mémoires et samara cup
series des notes sont magnifiques et
euros ont été versés sur podcast un gain
qui est venu nous parler de la mémoire
lui ça représente vraiment obsidienne ça
représente vraiment comme on nous
l'avait expliqué teddy jacques chaque
information tôt
plus il ya plus plus d'affaires qu'il
allait qui plus est chance que tu t'en
rappelles film et on
donne l'exemple de un nom d'une personne
brendon au ou seconde en remettons
pierre anne lefrançois 3 et le bien je
la salue ce métier je vous dire l'impact
de cette personnel à ma vie est vraiment
minime au point où est ce que j'aurai
beaucoup moins importante puis le est
important et
cette personne là dans ma vie est
beaucoup moins importante que plein de
monde que je me rappelle plus leur nom
c'est que j'ai croisé des dernières
années puis qui vont un impact sur
business ou alors que j'ai de la misère
à me rappeler leurs noms l'espace qu'au
secondaire il y avait tellement d'autres
souvenirs liés à cette espèce de toiles
d'araignées là que je n'oublierai jamais
son nom c'est que parce qu'il y avait
onze ans j'ai tous mes amis des
souvenirs la musique les nouvelles
affaires quitte à prendre et il ya
tellement souvenirs qui viennent se
placer dans cette espèce de toiles
d'araignées que pour toujours je vais
être capable de retourner à ses toiles
d'araignées l'appui me rappeler de bière
puis mais c'est ça pourrait si ça pour
vrai ces mêmes principes pour n'importe
quelle information t comme lot avait
quelque chose qui était allé chercher
les autres souvenirs auto pour te
ramener à souvenirs le 3 juillet l'image
du livre il manquait des bouteilles de
mots mais au début je n'ai juste pas su
rester sage et insurgés souvent c'est
vraiment cette logique parler d'autre
chose que le salage historique gérance
et celui
c'est un sens à leur insu fou à une
question par rapport à 10 mhz et on le
fait on d'emploi du temps pim et on
était objectif commun de soutien
puis moi je demandais le commandent
suggère mettons de côté je pense qu'on
avait parlé dans sa vie personnelle
sociale même si je peux un couple
non mais dans le sens c'est parce qu'ils
étaient moi mettons dans l'ic
l'équilibré l'emploi du temps de
différentes sphères de ma vie
la job sanin entraînement céder l'une à
prendre je suis vraiment personnel c'en
est une mais mettons mon côté social
amis blancs des terreaux à lyon qui
quand même important pour nous aussi
tout dans le fond parce que l'important
pour moi c'est quoi cela mais jusque là
au lieu de
deux les wanderers jeudi à rome c'était
papa en argent ou ça va arriver où on
veut semi tu vas voir que j'essaye de
faire mais c'est du lait de façon à ce
que tu peux pas tout c'est du lourd
mais maintenant exemple je peux sortir
récemment vu chose d'important pour moi
aujourd'hui socialiser bidet puisse pas
parce que celle ci faisait moins d'un
dollar du système - pourtant on est des
humains et de tout le monde même si je
sais les éléments déconnectés de mon
petit mec à moi j'avais structurer ma
journée c'était une façon que dans mon
côté personnel beige jardiner pas autant
monter maintenant c'est eux qu'il faut
qu'ils se mettre sur mon cou et se dit
même constat
c'est le pied mathis été verbalisés
quand même genre pourquoi puis dans tout
ça mais après seulement 6 d'entre eux
notons le maroc qui a tout fait ce que
je commençais ne font pas tout comme des
maps mais c'est quoi les fauves 6 le wii
ware que toi tu files le site et pas des
fois de cette rencontre que c'est
finalement toutes les voies de fait ce
matin je n'ai pas tant besoin petit peu
le remplacer deux équipes minimes fondu
puis c'est peu dire pour maintenant de
tes amis mais maintenant ce type de mon
immeuble à toutes les fausses aux films
de la même façon qu'ils s'en moquent ça
donne de quoi bac laisse pas tout le
temps de donner genre
financièrement ou de genre avait déjà
trois personnellement thème joyce et ça
donne plus de bonheur d'habiter
peut-être qu'il faut que tu fasses est
au-dessus suggère de faire autre chose
qui peut se construire directement john
peace fait c'est plus dans cette optique
le sais je sais quand même de ce qu'est
john toutes mes affaires puis si c'est
ce qui est drôle mais justement je fais
que jouer plus en plus en plus présent
que la personne ou les personnes nous
alerter j'essaie de me déconnecte qu'est
ce que c'est les autres
puis quand tu commences à faire ça tu te
rends compte que 20 des white à des
places puis finalement tu peux faire
plus d'une fois que tu aimes
mais ça c'est parce qu'effectivement tu
parles de wight is ok de le verbaliser
de même c'est un peu ronflant
terme de parties distinctes des jambes
des socialistes c'est qu'ils les
secteurs ça fait du sens en même temps
tu es puis puis on apprend souvent au
bape on apprend mais on voit souvent pas
ces gens déposent
dit non aux affaires qui vous amène rien
le truc demande mais c'est quand même
vrai parce que
le temps qui passe qui procure il est
temps que le temps que tu prends pour
faire de la pâte pro curien avec du
monde qui ne nourrissent pas maintenant
c'est du temps que tu passé du temps que
puis c'est pas du temps que pourraient
mettre dans ta business ou areva c'est
du temps que oui mais aussi le temps que
je pourrais passer avec des gens
meaningful qui qui va t'amener quelque
chose tu vas sortir du week end au parc
ça valait la peine en obtenant le stand
jeu outre une expérience qui était cool
on voulait juste tout affolement fin
donc j'ai un exemple montreuil à 13 ans
puis m'a texté nico massacrer des gens
qui va prendre ce complément envoyer un
texte de jules
paraphrasant mais les gremlins tout
comme ça me tente pas de dieu il dira je
pus plus d'amis je n'étais pas dans le
petit déjà je suis renfermée dit je peux
je peux faire des affaires et que juste
pour être cool pour le plus d'amis
j'aurais dû jouer vraiment genre
ses amis qui sont proches et ses guides
messi en a d'autres qui arrivent puis
des sages et sa canne iphone mais dix
jours il faut que sur moi puis me
développer puis je peux juste où il se
montait à suresnes style empire une
chance aux infractions premier niveau il
ya 13 ans y compris quelque chose c'est
vous les médias compris j'ai compris
quelque chose peut-être souvent ces
petits quatre chevaux du monde de
l'externe tout le même et un des
commentaires qu'ils avaient sous
l'ancien petit st mais justement faudra
cesser trop extrême peu importe mais
s'écarte et le professionnel dans ton
fils c'est ça c'est extrêmement ses sens
et de la baisse dès que c'est fait que
ça a l'air extrêmes le monde comme quant
au regard des 15 années péter kennaugh
whaou la natation est importante et en
extraire
ces extrêmes et regarde c'est pourquoi
on est déroutant mesmerize paramètres
jouent au public présent un billet
n'importe quoi c'était comme à la guerre
theillet
il faut être performant
ces malades sur les aspects ce que
demandent qu'à la volonté dispute monkey
mayhem est qu'ils peuvent aimer jouer au
basket mais y ont vu cette grippe c'est
senna mais il prenne 20% de caisse
qu'elle est l'extrême et metz était
professeur anton fait décent c'est
l'extrême peut inspirer les mondes le
monde alors on a d'ailleurs vu promettre
comme ceux mais c'est l'essence de tips
pour ceux qui on aime ce
musicien pour importer ce serait jeter
quand à voir si les meilleurs
podcasts en disant ça gueulait est trop
extrême il ya du monde aussi celle ci
olympiques parce qu'ils disent on
devrait arrêter glorifier la performance
à tout prix parce que c'est des vies qui
se met là dedans tu m'aimes mais je suis
collé ce malouin de cette mentalité là
de dire faudrait arrêter de glorifier
les gens qui font tout les sacrifices
turn over au contraire
mais c'est en fait le but de la vie
rurale
de faire ton sa réflexion pudeur mais
j'accepte ce qui gêne c'est que tout le
monde peut le voir comme état c'est pas
bon il est possible ça s'est écrite en a
tout de suite à vis social lui-même
encore peut-être même pas réfléchi à
exactement qu'est ce que tu veux gens
mais tu penses que ces sujets il faut
que juste là dessus mais ce sujet de ma
vie selon des critères exacts
oui petit café juste travailler mais la
personne et les arabes est malheureuse
peut-être trop d'arabes en place sauf
que jeudi cette présence a compris les
personnes et bien vous intervenez la
pression d'avancer puis-je à tous tes
goûts de ces personnes comme
pour eux quelque chose de pas correct
hébreu tipis et versements c'est pour
une autre personne la job ou à 9 heures
c'est pas quelque chose qui est un
portable est pourtant c'est passer du
temps avec les gens qui aiment qui et
c'est ce qu'ils appréhendent le faible
et 2 pouces il faut vraiment que la
moindre
réflexion je suis vraiment à 100% la
raison pour que je sais c'est qu'il peut
pas donner qu est ce que tu peux faire
que si tu veux vraiment être
incapable de je te le disais tantôt le
monde n'était que parler de ça leur
donne de quoi mais ça c'est juste parce
qu'il va chez google avec ses puissants
pour ça c'est moi je joue bien et je me
sens pas que c'est comme du lait mais si
tu es capable de la dame et on va
pouvoir donner bien presse auto moto de
tokyo vient général puis au monde en
fait cela c'est comment je sais que fut
jetée dans le moment mais le monde ils
savent qu'ils ont tout le temps
jaradi forêts sont jamais directes sur
ses toits toile pollué le pô j'arrête de
faire ça parce que ça rennes pour
installer personne ne sait vraiment
juste c'est fou comme un petit quelque
chose pour une fiction c'est simple mais
personne ne fait ça puis après cchm se
passer du temps avec ma famille et puis
j'aime jouer ici a pu observer comment
professionnellement je préfère le qu'est
ce que je suis mais tu penses tu attends
plus que moi ceci à pizza s'est troublée
cependant tu le fais mais si tu étais
vraiment étudiants j'aime ces caméras
les appuis ne fait pas seulement pour
l'argent mais très important pour être
prêtre à des expériences et ta famille
puis encore plus vif demeure encore plus
gros mais c'est une belle envie de voir
si vous voulez c'est lewis le les places
les 7 6 8 6 c'est sûr c'est pas de la
personne ouais je alors toi qu'est-ce
que tu habile mois d'affilée - à la une
chaque fois
dessus le dessus ou est ce que les gens
disent oui qu'est-ce que ça arrive tout
en excusant fond le pis je vais donc
fêté chez qui on offre notre note un
bleu tribune
c'est un style
une coupe afro sans viande votre client
qu'est ce que les gens peuvent choquer
pour suivre
ce sujet rien à vendre un de ces jeux
qu'on jouera j'étais à la fac sans vie
prêté 25 majoré de couleurs
suis je pense que va annoncer quelque
chose d'entièrement façon assez 6%
mais il m'a écrit et je s'entraîner pour
rg comme de s'acheter un créneau qui
marchent toute la journée
lara qui s'appelait comme indect on va
prendre ce
point extrême qui est négatif mais
maintenant exemple tout n'est qu'un kg
était plus jeune il le fait de
l'escaladé mais c'est un bon tir mais
décadent sac rouge en schiste bah oui l
apprendre à jouer du piano
lecteurs de ce mets et les vins commence
à chasser messages des marques depuis
les marches à tout les jours picot au
pied des six nations oui senna
merci marc aillet